Two.
That's it.
Wow.
A two count from young Jamie.
That's what the buttons and hit the other one.
Sorry.
Greg re,
how are you fella?
Joe Rogan always a pleasure to be back in a,
what I love is that you kept this studio the same as the old one because the
vibe was perfect.
I tried to recreate it as long as we had the desk.
We have the heart,
the heart of the studio.
The rest of it's just stuff.
And Jamie,
the heart and Jamie,
there's something about,
uh,
I,
I've,
I really think
when you use a desk for a long time,
there's something about desks.
Like if you found out like
hunters Thompson desks was for sale,
he'd be like,
Holy Shit.
Fuck.
I want to get my hands on that thing.
Like that's got some ooze.
You know,
he wrote on this,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Nice old one of those old like railway station roll top desks.
Oh,
those are the best.
Yeah.
I gotta protect my shit while I'm out.
So nobody reads my chair in one of my all time favorite
photos of him was him typing in big Sur,
like sitting on like this,
this outside table typing.
I think he's on the edge of a cliff or something like that.
In the background.
You see the water?
You know that photo Jamie?
Yeah,
that's it right there.
Oh,
look at that and put the pipe.
That is one of the most iconic writing photos of all time.
Hunters Thompson with hair with a typewriter in front of the water at big Sur
and probably like 1960 [inaudible].
And you know his schedule.
Did you ever read his schedule?
His daily schedule?
Not only did I read it,
he lived,
I read it on air and I might've read it on air with you.
I think you did a self portrait.
Hello?
You took the picture himself by saying,
oh,
so this was,
I mean it's what it's listed as.
This is in big Sur.
That was when he was in the early stages of his eruption.
That was like right around when he was writing hell's angels.
Probably 61.
Yeah.
That motherfucker was unique.
Did you ever see his documentary?
Now there's a couple of really good ones,
but,
um,
the,
the one that was the mainstream one.
What was that?
Yeah,
yeah.
It was called Gonzo.
And then there was,
um,
there was another one that was made by BBC.
That's really good too.
But yeah,
if you could get ahold of fucking Hemingway's desk.
Wow.
Yeah.
Let me,
let me maybe like,
worth too much.
Like you wouldn't want to write on it.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
It's Hemingway's desk,
like I can't ride on this fucking thing.
Yeah.
It was hunter's desk.
I'd tell I'd totally right on it.
Well,
first scrape the excess coke off the top.
Just lick it,
lick it off.
Wipe did jazz.
And from the underside of the table I'll get the badge sauce off the sides.
What about his typewriter?
How much you think it's typewritten?
Hemingway's house and hangouts preserved in Havana.
Wow.
So the preserved where he lived and
I wonder if that's where he killed himself.
I think he was in Cuba when he killed himself.
Yeah,
man.
His,
um,
his style of writing.
And like that whole bravado that went with him,
he was a different cat.
It was like,
uh,
you thought of him as like an aggressive male writer.
Like that's an odd thing.
Like Hemingway,
he was a aggressive,
yeah,
it wasn't,
you mean even Stephen King for all was most horrific depictions of violence and
Gore and terror in his books.
He's not thought of is like I said,
posing physical thing.
Well,
Hemingway was in the war.
Yeah.
You know.
He is elderly age.
He was a,
he used to go skiing in the winter in a,
I think it was Switzerland and they would all,
uh,
there was no chairlifts back then.
So you would fucking grab your 50 pounds skis and walk up the side of the Alps,
Jesus cry like a half a day to take one fucking run.
And he would do that every day.
That must be amazing for you.
Yeah.
God Damn.
Kind of exercise,
like carrying skis uphill in the snow.
Yeah.
That's incredible issue.
So I was like,
I bet there were jacked.
I put those skiers from the olden days.
Yeah.
They had to be like crazy athletes.
And the skis were long back then.
They were like twice as long as they are now.
When did anybody figure out a ski lift?
I don't know,
but I mean Hemingway would have been skiing in what?
The 1930s and 27
God damn dude.
Yeah.
The Walk Up Hill and ski down.
You gotta be dedicated.
Good.
Are you ever going to get,
I mean normally you do in a day,
maybe you do a dozen runs going up a couple miles and this one you do one run.
That's it.
Yeah.
You gotta be dedicated.
Try getting a,
like a lazy person to do that.
Lazy people will ski,
you know what I mean?
Because you just kind of get into it and you can get la Di da Di da.
You don't have to like get crazy.
Right.
You can just see like I'm not good.
So I ski like a Lazy Person.
Yeah.
I just like go,
don't fall,
don't fall.
Don't fall.
Didn't fall.
That's literally me scan because I've had knee
surgery three nights.
It's crazy.
How quickly you can fuck up your body skiing.
I am so,
I've skied my whole life.
I've never had an injury and I ski hard.
I hit ain't every fucking jump.
I can find
the only one that I know that like my friend Matt,
he broke his ankle or he broke his ankle and it happened in the course of like a
just a year.
Yeah.
Two friends at school.
Parents at school blew out their ACL.
Yeah.
You don't want to do that when you're 43 you don't.
Right.
That's the thing is you get to a certain age and you the risk reward because
injuries take so much longer to heal and you have so much less time to live.
You just,
the math doesn't work anymore to ski.
You've got to protect your knees if you can.
Yeah.
Your knees are so God damn important.
Whenever people have like hurt knees and they keep working out,
I always cringe.
Yeah.
We were like,
yeah,
I'm not going to get it fixed.
I'm just going to rehab it and like,
what do you,
we were talking about rehabbing.
No rehabbing.
You just going to ignore the fact that you don't have an ACL like rehabbing.
Yeah,
it was,
it get it fixed.
He's not going to,
you don't have the stability in your knees.
So there's a lot of guys who blow it out and they keep exercising and they just
chew the inside of their knee.
Yeah.
I got something going on in my,
the inside of my left knee for two fucking months.
If I try to squat down,
it kills is like a tended on the inside of the knee.
And uh,
so I'm,
I'm gonna start some physical therapy this week to try to figure it out,
cause I can't,
I have an exercise and fucking two months just because of this one thing.
What,
what am I going to do?
But I do more cardio.
I don't really lift that much.
Have you ever thought about getting like PRP or Regena keen or anything into it?
Oh,
now what's that?
Well,
PRP is platelet rich plasma.
And will they do is they take your blood and there's some sort of a process they
do and the separate it and then they take this platelet rich plasma and the
injected into the wounded area and accelerates healing.
A lot of people have really good results with that.
Yeah,
and then there's this stuff called Regena keen that's like platelet rich plasma,
but it's apparently the next step up and what they do is they heat your blood
and by heating it,
it produces some,
for sure.
If you're a doctor,
I'm so sorry that I'm butchering this if you're a scientist,
but I think it produces some sort of a anti-inflammatory serum because your
blood is reacting to the heat.
Right.
Here's the here explains,
I've had this done and it was really effective.
Yeah.
Serum removed from the layer and cultured with glass beads so that a white blood
white blood cells per to use r r a p which is a natural anti-inflammatory glass
beads going into your knee.
I don't understand what that's saying.
It says Cierra was removed from this layer and cultured with glass beads,
so it's removed after the platelet.
Rich Plasma said they made complete Louis Rich plasma.
They get the serum and then they,
and then they culture it so that the white blood cells produced this natural
antiinflammatory.
So they trick the white blood cells.
I guess maybe for lack of a better word.
Anyway,
so this shit,
it's really good for,
uh,
accelerating your recovery process for an injury.
Like a lot of people like do it like while they,
if they get surgery,
they get surgery and then they have some of this done to,
it accelerates the healing.
Right.
Especially as you get older,
it just provides you with a,
any,
it's actually natural to,
you don't have to worry about it,
but it provides you with this just an extra boost of healing for weird neck
injuries and back injuries.
People like it for,
it's really good,
really good for lower back injuries.
I'll have it as inflammation,
you know?
And so then they,
did they,
is it local?
They shoot the blend into the area?
Yeah,
it's hard.
it's freaky.
They put this little needle in you and then they screw the blood cap in there
and it's like,
now it's yellow.
It's like this yellow senior,
and they squirted into your back and you're like,
whoa.
Damn.
It's weird.
Yeah,
it's weird.
I think they would do my cock.
They get it up for you,
but I want your blood in my car,
dude.
I don't know if that's legal.
You can sell all kinds of things.
Right,
but you can't sell somebody your own blood.
Is that right?
I don't think so.
Do you think he could sell your own blood?
I mean,
if you to walk a blood bank,
right?
Sure.
There's a website you could probably do.
You think so?
Oh,
like a dark web and that whole myth about selling people's cases.
Yeah,
sure.
William Shatner would be dealing it if he could.
No,
no.
Fuck you.
You could just like,
if someone was selling blood like some,
you know,
there's a lot of those,
uh,
young enterprising young gals on the internet that smelled like dirty socks.
Oh yeah.
They sell toenail clips and share it.
I'm not kidding.
Yeah.
Nothing.
Nothing goes to waste.
No.
Nothing goes full blood for sale.
India is illegal.
Red Market.
What is this Jamie?
Oh,
this is like,
this is a,
they're doing it like medically though in an alleyway.
Yeah.
But that's how they do it there,
man.
That's crazy.
Or is there still a ban on a
Haitian people and gay people giving blood?
That's a very good question because they've,
they've gotten so close to stopping HIV,
they can get it like,
correct me if I'm wrong,
they can get it like to you to the point where you're,
you can't even detect it.
Oh yeah.
Which is incredible.
Yeah.
And then now in the third world,
because my,
uh,
my friend Peter Current,
he lives in a symbolic way and uh,
no,
Mozambique and he used to work for the health department in La County.
He was the guy that was in charge of AIDS prevention.
And so he got a job working over in Africa and he said that you can now cure,
not cure,
but stabilize somebody with HIV with a pill that's like $60 a month
or something like that.
Wow.
Yeah.
They've got the price way down in Africa now.
That's incredible.
Why is there's so many cases of HIV in Africa?
Um,
well I think when nutrition is poor but then there's more cutting and bleeding
because I had heard that a lot of what you see in terms of like if they're
talking about aids in Africa,
that it's very easy to put aids,
like put like that category aids,
um,
that sometimes it's just people with damaged immune systems from a host of
different diseases that it's sometimes people aren't getting tested.
I was wondered like how many those people are tested for HIV?
Right,
right.
What is,
but the fact that a guy like magic Johnson has had it since you remember when
you heard Magic Johnson had I was in a panic.
Yeah.
I felt like it was a Zombie movie.
Like it's happened.
It started and then people were just going to get it.
We're all gonna dive aids.
Everybody what our generation when you and I were like 21 that's what everybody
thought.
Everyone's going to die from AIDS right now.
Magic Johnson's looks great.
Yeah.
He's still alive.
I think of how many people who've died.
We didn't have HIV and we're worried about this one thing.
I remember he wanted to play in the all star game and all the players were like,
Nah,
I'm good.
It's to be a slam dunk contest.
But this Jesus Christ.
But what did,
what did fucking Damon Wayans you used to have a bit about Dennis Rodman
did.
It's about Dennis Rodman spit and then magic Johnson smile to accelerate his
symptoms.
He's like,
if he wanted to try to get hardcore with them,
I forget.
I hope he did.
Damon's,
I'm a huge Damon Waynes fan,
so I hope I'm not butchering his bit.
Yeah,
but I think that was one.
I know that was his line.
I'll spit in your mouth and accelerate your symptom.
Dude.
Damian Wayans my opinion is like one of the most ignored greats.
I agree.
100%.
I used to open for him sometimes and uh,
twice.
I remember him coming in on a Thursday night.
It was Thursday to Sunday.
Faneuil hall comedy connection.
Thursday night he comes in fucking yellow pads.
He goes up and just regurgitates a new hour and gets,
okay,
laugh for a new hour.
Friday night he comes back tighter,
tighter Sunday night.
It's like he would fucking destroy with a new hour.
It was so crazy.
He's really good man.
Yeah.
He would go,
he would just go up at the comedy store and literally let whatever thought came
into his head and he would take long sets and he would take that stuff and he
would turn that stuff into killer closing bits.
Yeah.
But for whatever
reason,
I think he just got into doing sitcoms more.
Right.
It was like,
Nah,
fuck it.
Yeah.
You know?
He's uh,
he's,
can I say interesting family man?
They,
you know,
they grew up in the projects in Manhattan,
Dude.
Talent and that family.
Keenan,
Damon,
Marlin,
Sean.
When Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
That's a lot of camps.
And,
and isn't Damon's son doing stand up to now?
Yeah.
Dude at Damen junior.
Right.
What a crazy family.
Now.
That's a crazy,
you better be in show business and that family or you're doomed.
Yeah.
Let me think about that.
It's like,
right.
Like,
if you want to compete with your brothers,
Keenan and every wins,
Damon Wayans,
Kim Wayins,
Sean wins,
bottling winds.
Damien Dante wanes.
Damien Wayne's junior.
That's all of them.
Yeah.
All of them in showbizness.
It's amazing.
Yep.
Good luck in to teen and the had a fucking great talk show how he yeah,
he was,
he was really good as a talk show host.
Yeah.
He was so talented.
Fucking family man.
But for whatever reason,
Matt Damon did this one,
a HBO special and I think he called it his last stand and uh,
it was really good,
man.
It was a really good,
and the end of it,
he just throws the microphone down and says,
look,
this is the last time I'm doing stand up.
Oh no shit.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's just like a decided he was going to do movies.
That's it.
Last stand with a question mark.
Yeah,
he got,
um,
you know,
he just got into other stuff,
but I'm telling you,
man,
when he was like,
go up and above go that photo though.
The one like that was the stage,
the baret wearing stage.
Yeah.
Dude,
I'm telling you,
people forgot.
He's one of the best,
one of the best ever do.
He would murder that one particular special.
It's just murderous.
He had a lot of great sets.
Yep.
On television,
but just like real original too.
Like one of those guys,
we would watch them and you go,
God damn.
Why didn't I think
well,
and his voices were so fucking good.
You know?
A lot of times people do their girlfriend voice and it's just,
it just sucks.
It just sounds like the guy raising his voice.
There's no like female intonation to it or anything and his kids voices and his
wife or girlfriend versus just fucking amazing.
Yeah,
yeah.
There.
Oh,
and then of course it's like Richard Pryor.
Richard Pryor.
So good.
I mean,
you had so many characters in living color.
How about handyman?
You could never do that too.
Yeah,
that's right.
You could never do that to a homeless guy too.
That's another show in living color is another show that people forget.
They forget how good it was.
Yeah,
there he is.
There's handyman.
They don't even show reruns of that show too,
that these are frail reruns.
A handyman.
I remember what it was on TV,
man.
No one could stop saying,
homie,
don't play that.
Everybody would say that.
Everybody was like,
Homie,
don't play that.
Like every kid would say that because homey the clown homie don't play that.
People Forget.
People fucking forgot about homey the clown.
They should come back.
Netflix.
Please throw some money at getting it back on the air.
They just tried to do it and it all fell apart.
What happened?
I know they had big money and uh,
I don't know if it was going to be the original cast.
I might've been part of the original cast.
I bet.
What happened with Jennifer Lopez who want to be a fly girl.
Yeah,
right.
She's like,
no,
she should jump on that shit.
That would be cool.
She jumped back in.
Was a fly girl again.
I mean,
how much time would it take it not that much time.
She's there.
I mean she probably could dance in her sleep.
Yup.
Damn.
I would love that to be a fire girl.
I don't know who else was a flag around any other famous ones.
That show was so good.
I remember watching it.
I was playing pool in Yonkers,
New York and I looked up at this,
this TV set and it was a Jim Carrey doing the,
the,
the fire marsh or fire fire Marshal Bill.
I was like,
what the fuck is going on?
Yeah.
This guy's got a burnt up face.
Rosie Perez was the core your ground for for the first four seasons.
Wow.
No,
Rosie Perez,
a giant boxing fan.
Oh yeah.
Giant boxing,
Huh?
Yeah.
Like people,
like she's like a boxing expert.
Not like an expert.
Like she could train fighters,
but like people asked her questions about boxing.
She's a real enthusiast.
That's a better term instead of an expert.
I mean maybe she is an expert,
I don't know.
But uh,
she is always around box.
I think it's so,
because you always think of her as having,
that's the cute voice and you know,
in all of those comedies and to see her at like boxing matches a really right
into it.
It's like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Cool.
Um,
and Jim Carrey,
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
he would,
he would do the,
uh,
the convenience store,
a security guy,
and he was just so big and so big,
so different than like,
I mean,
you have to go back to Jerry Lewis to think about somebody doing physical comedy
that well,
yeah,
he was,
he was a 10,
like his energy and everything was like the fucking ace Ventura movie.
Yeah.
Like that move was just all performance.
Like what does this one,
what is this Vera de Milo to that fucking show was so good.
Yeah.
People forgot.
There's fire Marshall Bill.
So I was in,
I was in this pool hall and I looked up,
I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
And they're like,
that's fire Marshall Bill.
That's,
that's what it is.
He came in like that.
I was like,
that is the creepy shit I've ever seen.
I can't believe they have a character like this.
It was so over the top.
Do you think Jim Carrey or maybe
uh,
the one of the Wayans brothers has bought up the rights for reruns because they
don't want that
blowback?
Yeah,
no,
it's a different era.
You have to accept as a different era.
You just,
people were different.
Look,
people are changing and it's really interesting,
obvious sign that things that were super acceptable.
And when was this in living color?
I want to say it was like 92,
90 to 94.
9,094 yeah.
So that the way you could do certain bits and what you'd get away with and put
on television,
it was just different.
So I think that's one of the,
like probably one of the least understood things that's happening with us with
social media is as the rapid evolution of what's acceptable,
not acceptable anymore.
And it's changing very quickly.
In terms of subjects,
in terms of the way you approach things,
in terms of like obvious bigotry or obvious bias,
it's like it's all getting very highlighted.
Well,
the,
I think the big question is whether or not you see an artist as somebody who's
taking their inner vision and putting it out and you go for the ride or you
don't.
Or is it,
are we supposed to be representing society in our standup?
Or is it all supposed to be fair,
balanced representations of different ethnic groups and genders?
You know,
and,
and it's like,
when did it all have to become a morality tale?
When did every depiction of every race have to be fair?
You know,
can't you have an asshole who's black?
Can't you have a killer who's gay without it becoming a depiction of that
entire,
you know,
subgroup?
Yeah.
It's like,
if what our real problem is that prejudice does exist,
so when it does exist,
you kind of look for it and things and you say,
hey,
this has the characteristics of prejudice.
I see this here.
I see what you're doing here that I think this is prejudice.
We say,
no,
no.
This is making fun of Puerto Rican men.
This is not prejudice.
Yeah.
This is,
uh,
an account of real occurrences that I've turned into humor.
Yeah.
The,
the flamboyant masculinity of Puerto Rican men.
I mean,
like in New York,
like that's if you,
if you thought of a type of a Latino sort of,
uh,
the bravado,
you know,
the music,
the food,
everything spicy.
Like if you can't make fun of that.
Yeah.
Come on.
I Know Collin Quinn does a whole thing about how racist,
right?
Puerto Ricans who never inside or outside,
they're always both.
Like there's always a window open.
People on the inside and outside of dogging the car door is always open.
They're half in the car.
They're half right.
This isn't racist.
This is observation.
Can I take an option rate?
Can I tell you that yesterday,
about twice a week I go to this Japanese market in Mar Vista and they've got all
different
kinds of,
uh,
you know,
you can get Sushi tempura whatever the parking lot for this place,
because 80% of the people that are Asian film it and put it on a fucking
television channel.
It is,
it is just people.
Why don't you produce it?
I could announce it like I was Adj Foy.
You're an Emmy award winning writer.
You could actually do something like that.
You're like a legit writer.
You could totally produce that.
Can you imagine announced it like Nascar.
It's just people like not getting how to get out of a parking spot with us
taking like eight k turns and people on the wrong side of the street and backing
up without looking over the shoulders and they're all Asian and it's fucking
hilarious.
I didn't,
I didn't tell them to do it.
I didn't say it was wrong,
but it's happening.
Yeah.
Dave explained it,
um,
why it's a stereotype,
but why also why Asian people would,
um,
be more likely to walk straight.
And,
you know,
like if you,
if you go to China or if you go to any of those,
uh,
Asian company,
Asian countries,
when people walk straight at each other,
they all kind of have this way of touching and they just,
there's so many people,
they're just grinding past each other.
Yeah.
So when you're in China in particular,
people are like indifferent to bumping into you.
It doesn't bother them at all.
They just bump into you.
Like if you're in the aisle of a plane,
they just bump into you.
Yeah.
Like they'll do it.
The little kids just walk right through it.
Right.
It's just,
that's how they did.
It's not rude.
Just like how's culturally different?
Yes.
It's more crowded.
Why can't you comment on that?
Or couldn't you comment on that?
If that's a real thing,
because that is a real thing.
They do do that.
Yeah.
They also do a lot of great stuff.
I mean,
it's not like you're not,
it's a negative judgment on the entire race because they have this one
characteristic,
but to ignore that one characteristic seems crazy.
Yeah.
It's like,
why can't I talk about something like,
I'm not,
it's not mean I'm not a bad person to talk about a real thing that you see and I
see.
Yeah.
I get booed on stage sometimes.
Now that never used to happen for what?
What'd you say?
I did a joke.
We don't have to say the joke,
but just say it.
I don't care because I don't think it's offensive,
but there's,
but this person did and it was uh,
you know,
I go,
oh it's girl,
it's girl scout cookie season.
Those little whores are out there popping up their tables wherever you are
selling those stale,
shitty overprice.
But you buy them cause it makes you feel good.
Like you're a good person,
you know,
and then you walked through the parking lot in some black kid comes up with a
box of snickers gone,
hey we use support my basketball team.
And you're like,
that's a fucking scamps
guy goes,
Ooh,
through not all skin.
I'm like,
that's not what we're saying.
Stupid.
Yeah.
You're doing a character.
I'm commenting on a very real thing my entire life I have bought girl scout
cookies and I have
not always bought that fucking snickers bar in the subway or the,
sometimes I do.
Yeah,
the girl scout cookies.
It's universally accepted.
Yeah.
Right.
But they only have like the ones that are like are the ones that,
it's like a coconut one with someone.
I like chocolate on it.
You that one.
This one's pretty Carmel.
One's pretty,
that was a legit,
but they've got one called
the muff,
but then there's also like there's steps away from girl scout cookies where,
well,
you don't have to participate.
Like when kids come over with chocolate or candy.
Thanks.
Good.
I don't eat that stuff.
Like you kind of have to buy girl scout cookies.
You want to support the girls camp,
but you know it's such a scam.
All that money goes to the manufacturer.
Apparently the girl scouts make like 20% of the the cookie money.
Really?
Yeah.
They're getting fucked.
A girl scouts again.
Fuck course someone came in.
Some ruthless man.
Probably the MOA.
Moa is,
that's exactly what it is.
Those are the shit.
Yeah.
With milk.
With a cold glass of milk.
Duncombe Yup.
Fuck yeah.
It almost tastes like neat.
Then look at it.
It's chocolate.
Eat Coconut.
He goodness.
Why do they have to be so bad for you?
When I was,
when I was working on a TV show,
one of the producers had a daughter who was in the girl scouts and I guess you
win contest if you sell over if you sell the most cookie boxes.
So when the audience would stream out after the show is a daily Shell and the
audience was stream out and uh,
the girl had a table set up to sell our cookies and she was selling a hundred
boxes a day and for every day she was there fucking won that contest dam.
And they would have the audience,
a warm up guy like plug it during the shell,
like after the shit,
like a comedian selling his cds after the show you go buy some girl scout
cookies on the way out and all these,
these fat people from the Midwest or like Kooky,
like Marie Callender's died.
Just have pie.
Just Pie.
[inaudible] Pie.
Yup.
Not even good pie.
It's good,
but it's not great considering it's all they do.
I should have eaten there.
I don't think I've ever eaten there.
Maybe I eat it one,
I don't think I had their Pi.
That seems a weird thing.
Like come selling pies.
Yeah,
Blake,
good luck.
It looks on pies.
You're going to go broke,
but they're everywhere.
We know you have an element.
We know you have flour branch out a little bit.
Like who the fuck gets famous as selling pies?
Like how genius is that company?
Admins member Edmonds intimates,
but then they,
they,
they broke out.
They started doing cakes and cookies too,
but they all,
they did just pies for a long time.
Dude.
They used to have this,
this Ah God,
this pastry.
I'm trying to think of what the hell it was,
but it had like,
like hard sugar on the outside of it and then it had some sort of creamy sweet
stuff on the inside of it.
Holy Shit.
Was it good?
Yeah.
God Damn it.
We lived off that shit.
We ain't meds every night.
They had like,
they had one that had like a chocolate filling in it and it was powdered outsize
filled
mine.
They went out of business and then they say,
oh,
that was the cheese one.
That was a good one too.
I remember the cheese filled crumb,
those,
they had some ridiculously delicious shit.
Yeah.
What are the other big ones?
You know,
I decided to fight in a tournament once because a,
I had a crazy sugar high from Dunkin donuts.
I'd hurt myself or hurt,
um,
something in my crotch and I couldn't work out for like a week that pulled some
sort of a muscle and there was a big tournament that was coming up.
And uh,
all the,
the guys that are competed with,
we're going to this tournament.
It was like I had just fought like a week before.
I was like,
I don't think I can do it.
I'm like,
this doesn't feel right.
I'm just gonna take the whole week off.
So I decided I'm just going to take off,
let this thing heal.
And so,
uh,
delivering my newspapers and I go to Dunkin donuts and I got this powdered lemon
filled donut.
I got one of those and I got a,
a Boston cream donut,
one of those.
And I got a,
I ate like three donuts cause I'd be exhausted,
tired,
drinking coffee,
delivering fucking newspapers for three hours.
And I was so jacked on sugar and coffee that I said,
fuck it.
I want to fight.
And so I drove.
I drove into town like right before everybody was leaving.
They were like,
why are you here?
I said,
I'm going to fight anyway,
man.
Like Beavis and Butthead,
I won.
I won the tournament.
It was a giant tournament for me.
It was big.
It was the American open.
It was like a big,
it's a big deal.
Wow.
Yeah,
it wasn't going to do it.
I got jacked up on sugar and made a rash decision.
I can see you winning the first match,
but then,
then you crash.
No,
you got to keep fighting.
it didn't.
It worked out somehow or another,
I guess I ate when I got there too,
but also the week off,
I'd never done that.
Like taking a week off.
Sometimes when you do something like that where you,
if you exercise too much,
you're really always in a state of recovery and your body doesn't get a chance
to like fully charged back up again.
So at the time I was probably 19 and I was going hard like every day,
every day that I could,
so I'd never really taken a week off.
So taking a week off and just be like,
wow,
this is,
I did take a week off when I started getting laid.
Yeah.
That is one thing that happened the first time he got late.
When I first started getting laid,
I took a long time off and at yelled at.
Yeah.
Like I yelled and I wasn't doing any training.
I came back all tanned and shit.
All he did was fuck.
That's a workout at
that age.
That's a workout.
You know that those weren't 20 minutes sessions.
Well,
it's weird how your,
your body changes from no,
no urge to fuck to like fucking is your whole life.
Like when you're 18 years old,
it's your whole life.
Like you found the craziest drug ever.
Yeah.
And like two years ago,
it wasn't in your life.
Yeah.
Then all of a sudden it's in your life and then all of a sudden you're having
sex and you're like,
I can't believe that.
Yeah.
And you can't believe that,
that women are letting you do it because for years they were stopping you and
now they're initiating.
Yes.
Can't leave.
They want it.
You actually want me to fuck you.
Yeah.
This is what you like.
Okay.
Yeah.
It feels wrong.
But if you insist it feels wrong that you like,
it is a weird mentality that we think it's wrong that they like,
is that a Christian thing?
So crazy.
I think it has to do with,
um,
initially if you read sex at dawn a,
he's got a really interesting series of,
uh,
thoughts on the origins of sexual behavior and why,
why we all sort of have adopted this one thing now.
What do you think?
Let me ask you,
I think it's Christian.
I know it is for me.
You know,
I got a lot of,
hey,
I got a lot of shame.
Yeah.
That all that stuff.
I think it has to do with people getting pregnant too.
Yeah.
I think it had to do with,
it was too easy for a girl to get pregnant.
And if a girl got pregnant back when people were fucking just barely making it
out of the caves.
Right.
It was either really good cause he had food or it was a real burden because you
had to take care of this baby now.
Now you're,
you're not going to be gathering food for us.
Right.
I think there was a lot of that going on.
So if you were going to be with a person and you decided to make babies,
you got to be sure that this person is going to be there and take care of
everything and you're,
you're all set up.
Yeah.
So you can't just be banging a bunch of guys on the side and having kids with
everybody.
Then who's going to raise your kids?
Right.
This guy's going to come over and talk to his kid and he's going to come over
and talk to his kid.
Yeah.
That'd becomes a problem.
Right.
I think that's,
and the amazing thing is that having kids back then for guys,
the reason why guys stuck around was,
you know,
we have 401k is an IRA accounts back then.
It's like when you,
when you couldn't gather anymore,
you are at the mercy of charity and so if you had a lot of kids,
you had a chance of being able to actually live into your old age.
Yeah,
yeah.
They would take care of you.
Yeah.
It's also interesting too,
because there was so much infant mortality back then that there was a,
a lot of places where there's real good evidence that they had fertility cults,
like they were trying to figure out ways to get pregnant more and easier,
and they're just trying to have a bunch of kids.
Yeah.
Because kids were,
you know,
kids tied a lot.
Yeah.
Then dying from injury and sickness and a lot of people died from sickness,
you know,
no vaccines.
Right.
When you just at the mercy and then also it's the beginning of agriculture.
All these diseases are emerging that we don't have immune systems for it because
they're being,
they're being jumped from like they're there,
they're jumping from pigs to people.
They're jumping from chickens and birds to people.
That's where the source of most of these pandemic diseases come from.
It comes from large scale agriculture.
Those funky pigs all tucked together in these little cages that doesn't come for
free.
Like there's some demons are being brewed in that mix.
Yeah.
Like this,
this,
what was this?
What was the source of,
um,
the Spanish flu,
which I think was the most deadly epidemic in u s history.
Oh,
is that right?
It was international too.
Was International for sure.
I think for sure it was the most deadly epidemic in the u s yeah,
but I think he came,
I don't think it came from Spain.
I think I want to say it came from somewhere around Virginia.
Does that bullshit?
This is going to take time probably in New Jersey.
I feel like it came from some sort of farm situation.
I don't know why.
I feel like,
I'm guessing no surprises.
Not more of that now because you see some of these like pig farms and they have
links.
There are lakes of waste.
Have you seen the drone footage?
Is that what we're talking about?
Oh my God.
Some guy fluid,
you know,
cause they have these ag gag laws,
which apparently one of them just got shot down.
Somebody sent me an email
that some,
maybe it was Idaho or Iowa,
one of those places.
One was,
I states that,
uh,
the,
ag gag laws got shutdown to ag.
Gag laws are,
say if you are working in a slaughterhouse and you saw horrific conditions,
you got your cell phone out,
you filmed it,
you could get prosecuted,
you would go to jail,
you could be sued.
Because if walking,
all of those documentaries that came out,
well it's,
they,
I think those ag gag laws existed as soon as they figured out that people could
film thing.
You know,
because a few people released videos of her and it looked,
those ag gag laws kept,
you know,
kept people from talking about a lot of creepy shit.
Like this video,
if you see this video,
this guy decided since no one's gonna give him access to film the place openly,
she's going to fly over it.
So he flew over with a drone Spanish flu thing.
Okay.
For many years,
medical historians and epidemiologists hypothesize that the outbreak could have
started in a British army base in [inaudible] place,
France or at Fort Riley in Kansas,
where the first American cases of the new strain of flu were recorded in March
of 1918 more recently,
experts have experts have proposed a third hypothesis.
The Spanish flu originated somewhere in northern China in late 1917 and swiftly
move to eastern Europe within 140,000 Chinese laborers and,
uh,
the French and British governments recruited to perform manual labor to free up
the troops for war time duty.
Wow.
Yeah.
I think more people died of that.
Then they die then died in world war one.
The fifth song,
50 million people were killed because of this damn,
whoa.
Just think about core disposal.
50 million people claiming,
look at this.
It says,
claiming more lives in a single year than either the first world war or the four
year long black death,
bubonic plague outbreak that swept Europe and Asia in the Middle Ages.
And this is one that for whatever reason,
people talk about the plague.
They talk about the bubonic plague,
like everyone's here,
but no one talks about the Spanish flu.
Like that's a rare,
it's not,
it doesn't get brought up that often.
If you see this number,
this number of people die.
50 millions of people in a year in a year.
Man.
People talk about how bad that is right now,
but that's not what they're saying.
They're saying it killed more lives in a single year than either the first world
war or the four year long black death people on.
It's when they have killed and that he may have kept one third of the population
was sick with it.
At least they didn't all die.
God Damn.
I mean he taught,
people think that the world is in such bad shape.
We don't have plagues.
You know,
there is a,
the the poverty rate for the average poverty rate in the world has gone up for
like the last 10 years.
There's less poverty,
there's less.
Starvation is more education.
You know,
there's a lot of,
there's a lot of good shit going on too,
but just think about that.
We haven't had a world war in what,
70 years?
Yeah,
it's been,
it's been quite a while.
Not to say it,
not to diminish the wars that are happening now,
but something that really affected,
you know,
the entire population always feel like even since high school that it's always
been like around the corner.
Yeah.
That was when we were in high school was the big fears that we're going to go to
war with the Russians.
Do you remember going into the coat room and putting your head between your
knees?
Did you have to do that?
I don't think we did that and we used to do this and we did the debt get under
the desk drill,
which is hilarious.
Get Out of the desk.
So stupid like Mitch,
this is a nuclear war.
Do these to tell you you're going to get onto your desk as if they had some way
to alleviate our stress.
Yeah.
I know.
Attending,
I could get under the desk.
I'm going to give you an answer.
Yeah,
yeah.
Nobody knew what the fuck to do,
so they just made up some nonsense.
Let's get under your desk.
Duck Duck and cover Nicolette war,
that linoleum is going to save your life.
Yeah.
Look at this.
This is the drill.
All these little kids underneath the tables.
What a fucked up thing to put in a kid's head,
man.
Just stop and think about how close we were to doing something so stupid that
this could have become a reality.
And how now think about how this is a reality in certain parts of the world.
Like in our place,
it's not,
but in other places it is.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's their life.
I mean,
especially when it comes to things like drone warfare,
that freaks me out.
I know.
It's very effective at shooting terrorist.
It is.
I know.
It's excellent.
It's also super effective at killing civilians.
Super effective.
Yeah.
And there's something about,
when you think about how,
how we're being perceived and the rest of the world,
there's something about not even being present for the accidental killing that
makes it just,
you know,
okay.
Twice as bad.
It just seems weird.
And apparently it gives him pretty severe PTSD.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I'm,
I'm laughing because I'm like thinking like that's so crazy that they don't even
have to be there and they're getting PTSD.
Like,
just the fact that they're doing it from a remote,
I heard that pilots are freaking out there.
Some of them.
Yeah.
I'm,
by the way,
this is just what I'm reading might not even be true now.
I read that sensationalized,
but I would imagine that would kind of fuck with your head.
Okay.
Yeah.
The first couple of times it'd be fun.
It'd be like a video game and then you,
and then we'd start to sink in when you heard,
when you heard the reports later.
Okay.
Yeah.
You'd have to,
so detach yourself from it that it would be like this growing thing in the back
of your mind.
Yeah.
He was just launching missiles into apartment buildings
and they're telling you it's okay.
Everybody says it's okay.
Yeah.
This is what you're supposed to do.
Um,
when I talked to,
uh,
this gentleman than I know that was in the CIA,
he said that all those decisions are done by lawyers.
How really?
Yeah.
Whether or not they do it or not do it.
He goes,
at the end of the day,
lawyers are deciding whether or not it's like likely to be successful.
What's the legal ramifications?
He goes,
when you're talking about that kind of stuff,
he was like,
seriously,
it's a lot of us decided by lawyers.
I'm like Whoa.
Cause they want to know if you show her operated the,
the siting and [inaudible]
yeah.
Yeah.
And they want to make sure that all the ducks are in order.
Which I mean,
is that better or is that worse?
I mean,
is it better to just leave it to the generals to design,
you know,
you get this cartoonish impression of what that would be like some general,
like the fucking guy from avatar would go down there who are going to fuck
everybody.
That's what everybody's worried about.
Right.
The character,
the,
the cartoonish out of control.
Murderous soldier.
Right?
Yeah.
What was the Kubrick movie?
Oh,
a full metal jacket.
Now the one with the,
uh,
Peter Sally's was in it and it was about how I,
how I something the nuclear,
Oh yes.
Dr. Strange.
Yeah.
Like the general,
yes.
Yeah.
They're always like cartoonish.
Yeah man.
You better hope guys like that are on your side.
Dr. Strange.
So that was a great movie man.
It was so weird to watch it today.
Yeah,
I watched it a few years back.
Did you really?
Yeah,
like maybe four or five years back and washed it and I was like,
wow.
It's so wild to watch these little captured moments in time where you can see
like people were different then.
Yeah,
like old movies.
When you watch old movies,
you know what the biggest indication that something's different is women didn't
work out that.
Yeah,
they weren't like fit like we are used to seeing a lot of actresses that are on
TV and the movies date,
they all do like crossfit or something.
They're all working out.
They're all taking gymnastics or something or they're doing spin classes and and
they have trainers and doing these box jumps and shit.
Like girls are built now it's a different thing.
If you go look at like King Kong look like Fay Wray and King Kong soft.
They just,
yes.
They're not even picking up their groceries.
They're built different.
Yeah,
and they don't last.
If they didn't do manual labor,
they don't last.
Some of them do when they do.
It's a shock.
Like Raquel Welch,
like deep into her sixties Janice is still hot,
so feel around right to the end.
Jesus.
Yeah.
It's a few of them that were so potent that they're,
they're spell lasted there.
Their entire existence is just started this Jane Fonda Workout Fonda back in the
day with the doggy thing.
What was that like?
1970s seven to me.
Damn,
that was crazy.
That was so fucking big.
It was the first time women were marketed to for exercise.
I think so.
I think before that women may be competed in athletic events like Diane sticks
and shit like that when they were young,
but then when they probably got families or moved on to jobs,
they probably stopped.
What is this one go?
A robot championship.
Oh my God.
Look at this as a choreographed dance.
This is so strange.
Oh,
that's right.
Do you remember aerobics click.
I'm going to take an aerobics class.
Yeah,
you remember that?
I'll be kind of just dance around and you would do stop,
feel the pump,
pop the pop and two and three and go.
They turn everybody gay for about five years.
But it all these guys,
look at these guys.
These guys are straight as fuck and they don't even know they're doing gay
stuff.
You know it's like,
it's like when before,
but he knew that Rob Halford from Judas priest is it is gay.
He used to make everybody dress up like him because everybody like kids that
were straight kids that we're huge fans that Judas priest,
they would wear the cap and the jet and wearing gay aesthetic like gay biker
looking right.
Tough guys.
Everybody got into it because they loved him because Judas,
it is so bad ass and he's such a fucking awesome front man that like he had
straight guys dressing up like a gay bike.
That's fucking hilarious.
And then he comes out and they're all so,
they're like,
what?
This so confused.
He did it in a concert.
There's 100,000.
No,
I'm just saying what if he did and they looked down and there were actual
wearing is what I like in my men.
I had him on a show I did once.
It was a,
it was like to this,
um,
thing for VH one called the list.
Oh yeah,
I did that.
You did it.
You do host it too.
Yeah.
Here he is.
Look at that.
I mean,
look at the outfit Bro.
Seriously.
Wow.
The leather paper boy hat on.
Or it's more like a soldier's hat and he's got leather vest on with no shirt
underneath.
Leather gloves at spikes all SNM shit.
Tight,
tight,
tight leather pants.
It's hilarious.
Freddie Mercury.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
what was my point?
What we're,
we're,
we're talking about something right before we were talking about that.
Oh,
the,
the aerobics aerobics guys.
Like,
come on,
man.
They had dudes were in singles.
Look at this.
Look at this outfit.
This,
that's like a singlet from wrestling,
but with long pants.
Yeah.
This is bananas that they got man addressed like this.
Look at what they're wearing.
You see their nipples,
like their nipples are popped out,
they're all super gate out.
Then they pick out those three quarter length Reebok high tops.
Exactly what the velcro you had to get the velcro.
That's the newest technology.
Yeah.
So look,
every girl is dressed like,
you know,
I guess they look more like why they have two different outfits.
The girls have some of them expose the mid drift,
like the dirty girls that they are.
And the other ones that we're a a one piece.
Oh Alan Thicke was hosting this mother fucker.
Oh Shit.
Course he was,
oh shit.
Look at him.
Look at that hair.
It's wonderful.
Look at his jacket.
Solve Miami vice doubt.
Yeah,
he's got shoulder pads.
You got up,
got to get rid of the shoulder pads.
Back then you could have shoulder pads.
And I remember having shoulder pads and my first jacket.
It's nice.
It makes you look better.
It isn't like a stuffed bra for a girl.
It is.
Yeah.
It's the same thing.
But how weird that people,
so do you remember people actually dressing like that and in a class situation,
did they go to classes,
dress like that grade school?
We had uniforms and stuff.
So no,
I see.
If I never took it a robotics class.
But see if you could find video footage of an aerobics class.
If all the guys that dress like that,
those dudes got punked.
Yeah.
Somebody talked him into dressing like a dancer.
And they're not showing the kids this video.
Why not?
So you used to be stupid.
So what if you're stupid once you're stupid forever.
Is that real?
Come on.
Your kids love seeing you looking stupid tiff.
And you should tell him I had a mullet.
They laugh.
One thing that I always do and I told my kids would do something wrong.
They've done something wrong.
I say I,
I did worse,
way worse.
I did exactly what you did and I lied about it.
I always lied.
My parents asked me if I did anything wrong,
always loud.
And I'm like,
I know if he did something or you didn't do it,
I'm not mad at you.
I'm just trying to make you not do it in the future cause I want you to learn
why it's bad.
And so I would always tell that's good.
The number one thing I always do and I get mad sometimes.
I mean it's just there's,
there's no way you can't sometimes,
especially as they get older,
they get upset about things and you got who you got to calm down.
You gotta to like figure out how to calm down and stop screaming at each other.
Sisters scream at each other.
You took my thing.
That's fine.
Yeah it's not,
you gave it to me.
No,
but I can take it back.
That's amazing.
The pitch they can get.
Cause usually when people get that hostile to each other,
you,
you're worried there's going to be a physical fight.
But sisters can take it two,
three times.
That level it makes you so uncomfortable,
but then they'll cuddle with each other.
Yeah.
It's funny.
That's sweet difference.
Two years.
Yeah.
It's interesting watching them evolve,
like watching them learn new facts and learn new things and wash their little
brain filled with information.
Their vocabulary starts growing and you're like,
wow.
Yeah.
And you realize like,
Eh,
I mean,
I've said this before,
but it bears repeating.
We look at people in a static state.
We're always looking at people like if I see a guy and he's 40 years old and
he's an asshole,
oh that's that 40 year old asshole.
That fucking guy.
I know that guy.
That guy is so annoying.
But you don't think are that was a baby.
Yeah,
that was a baby with a bunch of shitty data thrown out him.
A bunch of Shitty interactions,
bad genes,
bad environment.
Maybe some alcoholism,
maybe who,
maybe some,
uh,
throw it in all of it,
right?
The lady HD
bad nutrition.
Throw it all in there,
throw it all in there.
A bunch of bad breaks in life.
Throw it all in there,
you know,
I mean that happens to so many people.
So you look at them and instead of,
I always like look at what they are now like,
oh this guy.
But what they are,
all of them including you and me is a baby that became an older thing.
You know,
and a great deal of people whose lives are chaotically fucked up.
It's through no fault of their own.
It's a great deal of him.
It's a large number.
Right.
You know,
and as I've gotten older and tried to be more compassionate and more,
uh,
more understanding,
more patient,
those are the things that I worked on a lot and I still struggle with it.
But um,
it's,
I don't think that's anything you ever really,
totally get over,
but you get better.
You get,
I've seen a lot over the years here.
A lot more patient.
Yeah.
I think a lot of that has to do with just getting better at being a person when
you work on it.
But I think also a lot of it has to do with my change of my attitude about
people and that I,
I started to think of them as
a product of a lot of different interactions and that we,
like,
you hear the term white privilege,
it's a fucked up term,
right?
It's weird.
But you have to admit,
if you're a person and nothing completely catastrophic has happened to you and
you became this 50 year old successful comedian that's an Emmy award winning
writer and like,
Yay,
bad things happen to you.
Right?
But they could have been fucking way worse.
It could've been way worse.
And for some people it is fucking way worse.
They just got a shit roll the dice from the jump and it's been bad experience
after bad experience and fucking abuse and violence and jail and the,
the,
you can't get out.
There's no way out.
You can't even read.
She's like,
you're frothing around at see,
trying to keep your head above water
and you run into them when they're 32 at a gas station.
And it's as much,
it's a,
I mean,
it's not saying it's not their fault because whenever someone does anything to
you,
it's their fault.
Like if someone commits violence on you,
they shouldn't have done that.
It's their fault.
That's agreed.
But what were the underlying factors that led this to happen?
And for all this talk that we do in this country about,
uh,
about violence and crime and the problem of violence and crime,
nobody ever looks at it in terms of like,
how do you stop children from being raised fucked up and violent?
How do you stop them from being abused?
How do you step in you that cause that's the root of all of it,
right.
And I think early childhood education can make a big difference because if you
have a kid growing up and you know,
the dad took off,
there's no money,
he's living on the streets.
If you can create an environment for that four year old to come in and have two
decent meals,
a nap time,
some structured play,
it makes all the difference in the world because that can become like the family
to them.
Now let me ask you this,
cause this is the,
we're in the biggest crisis in terms of immigration,
in terms of national discussion.
The biggest discussion of it,
they're not going to ever remember right now.
This wall shit where the government is completely shut down and no one's budging
on either side.
And all these government workers are not getting paid and so on because Trump
wants $5 billion for this wall.
I'm not.
Let's just,
in an ideal world,
it would be ideal if the way the world worked was the way America works where
you could just go wherever you want.
That'd be the ideal world.
If the whole world was America in the in the sense of you can go to New Mexico,
you didn't have to get paperwork signed.
You don't have to know.
It has to tell you whether or not you're allowed to go visit or not go visit.
He just drive there.
That's,
that's a nice thing about America.
It's almost like Europe,
but you don't need a passport.
Not In,
it's like Europe.
I know you guys have been around longer and all that good stuff.
That's not what I mean.
I mean in terms of there's a bunch of different fields.
It's all speaking one language,
but like there's a big difference between visiting Montana and visiting Miami.
You know,
if you go to billings,
Montana and hang out with the local folk at a coffee shop and then you go to
some fucking crazy after I already after hours party in Miami and Miami beach at
four in the morning and p did,
he shows up and fucking,
you know,
and there's all these celebrities and people are doing coke on the floor and
like,
what the fuck is this?
This is a different world.
It's a different world and there's a bunch of these different worlds.
New York City's a different world.
You know,
La is a different world.
You're allowed to go there.
Wouldn't it be great if the whole world was like that?
You can just kind of go wherever you want it to go and it would all sort itself
out.
The idea is you can't because it would fuck up our quality of life and would
make us less safe.
And I get the argument,
certainly you don't want to bring in criminals and murderers.
You don't want drug dealers making their way into this country and starting gang
violence and all that stuff.
Yes,
you're absolutely right.
And to deny that I think it's pretty fucking foolish.
Yeah.
I think it's a matter of like there's a lot to it.
It's a fluid.
The border is always going to be fluid and it needs to be fluid.
You know,
we need the immigrant spirit of coming in and a lot of them do start small
businesses when you know,
and again,
when they're brought in legally.
Um,
and so how do you,
how do you create a flow of people that is good for us cause they say most of
the immigrants that come here are the smartest,
sharpest people,
most driven and wherever they're from.
So we're actually drawing a really good,
you know,
be,
they talk so much about the criminals,
but the truth is most of them that are coming over here are the ones that
probably have the most to offer to this country.
Well exactly like our parents' generation.
Like our grandparents,
like my grandparents.
Like when did your,
your grandparents come over here?
It,
was it your grandparents or
teen 10 my grandparents.
Yeah,
mine as well.
My grandfather was one of 13 and 12 of them came over here.
And they lived in a two room fucking mud hut.
Somehow they kept finding the money to send one kid over at a time.
Like usually when there were about 15 whole crazy shit.
Yeah.
See that kind of shit is what I'm talking about.
Like those kind of people,
shouldn't they be allowed to come here?
That's,
that's how this thing got started.
The real problem is that their spots that suck as the real problem.
It's like we were talking about like white privilege.
White privilege is not the problem.
The problem is racism.
Racism doesn't exist in everyone's exactly the same.
And then we're okay and then we don't need to worry about white privilege.
What the real problem.
You're not getting,
you're not getting racist things thrown at you the way black people are.
Yeah,
for sure.
But that's not the problem.
The problem is racist things being thrown at black people.
It's not that I don't get it right.
It's say you get it right and it's like it took to highlight the fact that it's
not happening to me.
I get what you're saying.
But the real problem,
we're,
I think it's a distraction that the real problem is the racism itself.
The real problem is the,
when you see actual Nazis in 2018 2019 actual ones,
real ones like not,
not just dressing up cause they think it's a hoot.
You go move rebel.
I'm fucking road.
I got a piece of tape under my nose.
The,
there's a fucking people that aren't really Nazis,
but they're dumb here.
Right.
But then you see a real Nazi in 2019 you're like,
okay,
that real racism.
Yeah.
Now when they go into a,
I was in Portland and they said there's regular clashes like once a month
there's a demonstration and it's either the alt right having a demonstration and
then the a,
what do they call them?
The something far Antifa Antifa show up and they have regular fights and it's
fucking Nazis.
God Damn.
Oregon's a fucked up state because it was originally,
there were no black people allowed in Oregon.
That's the,
that's the,
you know,
cause now Portland is,
is very progressive,
super progressive or acid,
but there's no black people there.
So it seems there are,
it's,
he feels a little hollow that when you're there,
I just did new year's Eve shows there and they were,
they were,
it was all white.
It was all white.
It was weird.
That is weird.
There.
Dot.
If I was black I would go to Portland and his second,
you'd have so many friends instantly.
Everybody wants to high five.
You have you over for dinner.
It's um,
the real problem for sure is any kind of discrimination because that,
that also fucks with us too because if,
if people are discriminating against people,
we can't even make fun of them.
Now we have to leave him alone because he's punching down like,
but it's right there.
The best joke,
I mean when you think about it as a stand up,
what your topics are,
race,
racism,
sexuality,
politics,
it costs,
people don't do politics.
I know.
I would say the average comic is talking about two topics.
Racism and sexuality.
You did a great job of co covering politics without,
uh,
actually being political.
You do a great job with that.
You're,
you're Hillary Clinton bit.
Yeah.
I,
I did this thing during the election about her and I didn't mean it to knock
her,
but it really wasn't about knocking anybody.
It was about her having a dry pussy and you know,
that's the kind of political comedy you can expect from me.
It was also about countdown till Trump calls her a con.
That was my favorite.
It was my favorite line about the election.
Dude.
I did the,
I did the dry cut jokes about her and then a true Carrie was in the audience and
he came up to me after the show.
He gave me an entire piece of paper with more jokes on that premise.
He had tears in his eyes.
Like that's the thing I've ever seen
here.
Take these.
He loves filth.
Drew Carey's one of the nicest guys you ever.
Yeah,
he's great.
I met him at the Improv and dude,
he talks to everybody.
He was given young comics advice,
telling them write a joke a day.
Just one joke a day.
Yeah.
You get one joke a day.
That's good advice for a week.
You've got seven jokes.
Make yourself write a joke.
Yeah,
that's right.
How do you write a joke yesterday?
Nah,
I wrote some shit that wasn't funny.
That's root some shit.
Yeah,
we did.
You and I did the store together last night.
Yeah.
And the last night I came home wrote.
I'm just,
um,
I,
I've in this stage of a couple of these bits and I'm working on right now where
the,
they're just like,
they're on Bambi legs.
They'll go south on me.
I'll lose the script.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's interesting because when you go from doing a special and then chuck and
everything out and starting from scratch,
it's the most fun time.
Yeah.
Cause you're like a,
you look,
you're a beginner again.
You thinking about it all the time.
I'd like after dinner I've got a half hour.
I'm like,
I want to get back to that bit.
Yeah.
You think that you're thinking about it all the time.
Like you're thinking about bits all the time.
Whereas once you have an act together and you could do,
you do an hour,
20 minutes easy,
then you're not thinking about it that much.
You're thinking about when you do it,
are you thinking about it when you're right,
but you know,
thinking about it all day?
No.
You're tweaking it in in motion.
Like when you're on stage and you've got the hour down,
that's when we,
you and I were talking about a comedian you just told to take a little extra
time before they did this special and it really is and that extra few months
that you find emphasizing this syllable makes the joke,
get an applause break instead of just laughs.
It's also one of the most interactive art forms ever.
Whereas you need other people to do it.
You need other people to watch.
There's no way I can do that without you,
without people listening,
the watching,
whatever it is.
I can't,
you can't do it right.
You need them because they help you make it.
Their reactions to what you're saying tightens up what you're saying right
there.
Reactions to make you throw away.
Certain parts just aren't working right,
but you think it's funny.
They don't think it's funny.
Like how many times did they not think it's funny before you decided that part
might not be that good?
Let me concentrate on this part.
This part seems to have fruit to it.
This part,
this is the part that kills,
I didn't even expect this part to work,
but this partner and become a bigger part of the bit than the first part and
then weird stuff starts branching off,
but I don't think branches off in front of people.
Yeah,
it's weird.
No,
it really is interesting.
If,
uh,
if you could track a comedian writing a bit,
a good comic who really takes on a premise like you do,
like take on a thought or a philosophy and step it out as far as it can possibly
go and walk,
track that person doing that set for six months.
It can morph to where this almost nothing left from the original premise all the
time.
Yeah.
Sometimes I'll take an old joke and I'll use it as a scaffolding.
Like when I'm writing again and I've got no luck,
I'm trapped and I'm like,
[inaudible] no way to get from this bid to it,
but not going the old joke.
I'm a shovel old joke in there.
And then
from that,
like the little bursts that you get out of that,
we'll carry on and make the s the next premise better.
It's got a little bit more momentum to it and now you can explore it a little
lightheaded,
a little lighthearted,
little little easier,
less tense because the new stuff,
think about it.
That fucks me up the most is that I'm not exactly sure what's the best way to do
it.
So I'm thinking about while I'm saying it instead of just being in the moment,
right until I,
until you can just get it to the point where you can be in the moment,
it's just clunky,
but because it's clunky,
you're nervous and because you're nervous,
you're thinking about it all the time.
Yeah.
So it becomes like this obsession.
So if I feel like more premises start popping up that way,
it's weird.
It's like you have this hyper focus that's way less comfortable than being like
having an hour and 20 down ready to film.
Yeah,
it's way less comfortable,
but it's probably more productive in terms of like creatively of course,
but I always,
I always think of like,
it's like learning a new language.
Every time I have a new bit,
it's like,
how do I translate this thought in my head into like you said,
what's my approach?
What's my strategy to get that idea across?
And so you're thinking about that and it slows down you.
Yeah.
You're not in the moment as much.
I think I'm going to start doing some real late night sets too.
That's a good idea.
When you gotta do tired people,
right?
Like 13 people in the room,
you got to try those.
Those little spots out to you can get a little too used to do and crowds and if
you're a little too used to and crowds,
what happens is people want to laugh.
They want to laugh.
The dare to have a good time.
When you get at one o'clock in the morning,
they've already laughed.
They,
they've laughed and laughed and laughed and they've laughed for hours.
Some of them,
some of them get there at nine and they stay till two.
Yeah.
They just get up to pee or another drink,
have another seat,
and you're watching a crazy lineup of comedians you get on at one o'clock in the
morning.
And I'm like the dawn Barris hour,
that fucking you're,
you're getting in front of people that have seen everything.
So if you make them laugh that that's a legit bit.
Yeah.
If you can get through to these people when they've probably heard everything,
well then it gets you in your voice more because when there's only 15 people out
there versus 300 couple hours earlier,
at 300 you're performing something out to the back of the room.
They talk about playing to the back of the room.
In bigger rooms,
you have to be more physical,
you have to slow down and,
and then when you have 15 people,
all of a sudden you're in your human being,
talking to human beings voice.
And sometimes that's where you can find really the flow of the joke a lot better
because you're not,
you're not pumping it up,
you're just saying it.
Yeah,
I agree.
But I think you have to do those larger places too,
just to know how to do them.
Like there are different thing you can do a big theater,
a big theater need to
be comfortable with the fact that there's,
you know,
x amount of thousands of people in that room and in,
unless you do a bunch of those,
like you and I have done a few of them together.
Yeah,
they're fun.
Yeah.
But you have a time.
There's a timing thing that's different.
You have to like wait a little longer.
You can't,
can't beat your punchlines like one after the other.
Like you can in a club and the club you could just keep,
you can keep hammering because there's only so many people in the room.
We won't overpower the sound system
and that's why for so long comedy central,
the mandate was always they want the special shot in a nice theater like a,
you know,
1500 2000 seat or where they can get that big,
the crane camera shooting down and,
and the truth is for most including myself,
I'm not a theater comic,
I'm a club comic.
So all of a sudden I shoot my special in a room that holds 1600 people and it
was in,
I don't look back at it and go that's exactly how I want it to be.
Sane.
I was slower,
I was,
I was bigger and it's like I would have rather done it in a like a nice little
400 seat club
also.
You weren't doing a lot of those places so we weren't comfortable with it.
Like when you do those really big places,
once you get comfortable with it,
you start treating and liquor club.
Yeah,
like one of my most comfortable sets was one of the biggest places ever did the
Scotia Bank arena in,
in Toronto at the end of my tour.
But is at the end of the tour.
The very last spot before the Netflix special came out.
So I had,
I'd been doing stand up like real regular in these big giant ass places for
months.
So when I got there it felt like the store felt like doing the main room.
It was just a bigger main room.
Right.
You know,
you just,
it was just fun.
Just have a good time.
Yeah,
it's just doing a lot of those.
You got to do 'em but you really do have to do the little tiny shitty ones.
You've got to do those 1:00 AM spots.
You've got to do those belly rooms spots.
Yeah.
That's a big one.
The peli rooms a big one.
That's him right there.
It is.
If you are not connected to them,
they do not laugh and a few are connected.
It's the greatest crowd because there's only what,
60 people in there,
huh?
Oh something like that.
I also like doing alternative room.
Sometimes I go to Largo,
go up there in front of the cool kids and you know,
have to be a little more PC and
you should have a fake act that you do only for Largo,
like put together.
Actually I did Largo with a Whitney a lot.
I like Largo Hardwick was on that show too.
And um,
someone else,
maybe Adam Ray.
No,
Adam Devine and um,
and uh,
it was a fun time and it was really fun.
Largo is a really interesting old place too,
but all those,
those are all seen things like I would love if somebody did,
they put an act together that's only for like that crowd,
but it's like just onion ask enough that it sneaks through,
you know?
Yeah,
right.
Just a really like a guy who plays like the strongest ally possible for
everything,
for Trans Rights,
gay rights rights,
women's
rights.
It's like the ultimate ally or norm,
everything Birkenstock,
whatever.
We can do whatever we do to make them a character and then write really good
jokes.
Right,
right.
Really good.
Jokes like that would be an interesting approach.
Almost like a Borat type project.
Like create an all comic who's like,
who's really calculated,
who's really probably just trying to get pussy.
Right.
But,
but,
but puts together the right words,
you know,
if you don't support intersectionality,
then get the fuck out of my face.
Yeah.
And then he should try to get laid after every show as part of the care course.
It'd be just super sleazy with coke and needles.
Fucking syringes evil today
he's got shaky bottles of bills.
It takes the pussy hat off his head and starts fucking it backstage.
He's got a flashlight for a pussyhat.
Oh my God.
There'll be a hilarious character.
The thing
about people is who are you really?
And when you're like,
when you're talking to people,
do you know who you are?
Do you,
you sure you know who you are?
Like,
are you 100% certain and cool and calm?
I don't think most of us are.
Like most of us are like constantly evolving the way we behave in think,
constantly thinking about it.
Maybe things went wrong last night.
I got to stop drinking.
There's always like something like,
oh,
I gotta get my ass to the gym.
There's always something.
There's always something you're trying to improve and move around.
So if you are a person who is,
you know,
if you don't know exactly where you're coming from but you want to sell that,
you know where you're coming from.
He wanted people to believe you know where you're coming from,
then you,
then you get all this momentum behind you and you almost can't get away from it.
You know,
like you're,
you're like,
you see this a lot with people that are trying to be spiritual
or they're always trying to sell you on the idea that they're spiritual.
They're always pushing.
There's,
this is me,
man,
this is me.
Are you sure?
I can think who we are.
All of us is,
a lot of it is like who we've encountered and how we've interacted with those
people.
Yeah.
And then the uniform comes along with it.
And the Diet,
there's like a whole follow this manual that,
you know,
they talk about hipsters,
which,
you know,
it's a pretty wide umbrella.
About what kind of hipsters there are,
but just the idea of wearing a uniform always kind of puts me off on people like
you stopped,
you stopped growing if you're going to put on what all the other people that you
want to be like are wearing.
Yeah.
This is the thing.
It's like the opinions aren't necessarily wrong because they're your opinions,
but the thing of the,
the thing of any kind of ideology,
whether it's a hipster all ideology or if it's a fucking conservative,
right wing farm worker ideology.
Like when people adopt those,
it's very little deviation and a lot of times an not even really thinking
entirely about what they're saying.
They just,
they just know what is going to get the right positive reaction from their clan.
Yeah,
I feel bad.
My Mom,
who is,
you know,
we grew up pretty liberal family in New York.
My Dad was in radio and he talked politics on the air and it was pretty far left
reading that,
you know,
my mom worked at the New York Times,
he can't get any more liberal in that.
And so then she moved down to Florida where everybody watches Fox News in her
building and they all sit around the pool and they fucking berate her because
they don't agree with them.
And I just say,
good for you mom.
You haven't,
cause a lot of people go down there and they were,
they changed their views because they are so,
you know,
intimidated by not fitting in with the,
it's your social group.
It's a different country.
Florida's different kinds of saying American Europe.
Right.
And that you go to Florida does a different country.
Yeah it is.
And it's,
it's two different countries because if not three,
because you've got the locals,
which I'd put them against Mississippi and Alabama for being deep south.
And then you've got the retirement people,
which is old Jews from New York and then you've got the Latino Element Florida.
It's V it's three different,
a lot of old Italians from New York to Oh yeah,
that's right.
All those people just as at fault this winter we get Nadie.
Yeah.
What do we do?
Talk and get in the boat
down as hard as you fucking cunt.
Get some good Italian food in Florida.
Oh yeah.
Got some good food.
But yeah,
you're right.
The upper part of it,
especially,
that's like all that mean,
might as well be any other southern state.
Right,
right.
And then at the bottom it's Cubans.
Yeah,
no running shit.
And Miami.
Miami's just international.
Miami is like an international city.
It's like an international city that's in America.
That'd be that.
It's so different than Seattle.
Like in terms of feel and like the way you're walking around,
everybody's like thin and in tight clothes and you know,
people are partying and fucking dancing and music's coming out of cars.
Like,
Whoa,
hey,
spaces alive.
Yeah.
It's alive and it's going to be underwater soon when they get a suit.
And when the moon is in certain positions in Florida,
it doesn't even matter what tide is.
The fucking,
if it,
if there's a high tide and no storm,
they still streets still flood in Miami.
It's getting bad.
Is that real?
Yeah.
Well,
here's what they gotta do.
They're gotta dig under the city and then lift it up.
Yeah,
that's right.
Just go all the way under Ilan mosque.
Use that on machine thing and you want to put some giant metal bars and just
jack it up to chick,
chick,
check,
check.
He got the Italian down there.
They do construction,
but what if they do in New Orleans deal where they put up a levee?
Yeah.
That's what they're going to need to do.
Jesus Christ.
I think the problem with that though,
what I read was that there's something about the porous nature of the soil in
Miami that the waters are going to come to the ground.
Yeah.
The ground under the cities of south Florida's larceny for the IRD,
it's largely poorest live.
Jamie's on the ball,
largely porous limestone,
which means water will eventually rise up through it,
so they're fucked.
They're fucked no matter what.
Even with a levy there fucked that.
Water's just going to get through the ground right up.
You know how like you're on the beach and you could dig a hole in the sand and
eventually you hit water.
Yeah.
That always freaked me out.
Yeah,
I know.
I now
wait a minute.
This water under here.
How much water?
However,
my kid was sitting in one of those holes and I'm like,
you're going to get fucking sucked underground.
Yeah.
I didn't like it.
I was,
uh,
listening to a radio lab podcast on quicksand.
It was really cool podcasts because it made me think I went,
oh yeah.
Nobody worries about quicksand anymore.
Is that a real thing when we exact kids,
dude?
Yeah.
Quicksand is a real thing.
It's a real thing.
You can fall into this soupy,
watery sandy shit,
and if you don't try to swim out of it,
you try to walk out of it.
You could drown.
Yeah.
You could die in there.
People have definitely died and you might not even get out if you try to swim
out,
but that's how you handle it.
You handle it the same way you handle water and if you try walking through it,
yeah.
Like people just get sucked into the Merck.
I mean,
if you,
if you think about it,
there's like a certain amount of density to what you need to stand on.
Right.
That's why mud,
it's not hard.
You use,
you just go in there and you can get really stuck.
Right.
Well if it's more watery than that,
then what happens?
Well then you can't even stand then you
people just panicked.
Wow.
Yeah.
You've got to swim.
If you can,
because there's all this weight on you too.
You have to realize that that stuff's dense.
So it's watery,
but it's also heavy and then your clothes are covered in it,
so your clothes become really heavy
and so nobody can save you because if they get close,
they're going to fall in.
Yes.
Yeah.
If,
if they,
you know,
if you're going to drag them down,
man,
they,
it's hard to swim with somebody.
You know that as well as anybody.
You saved somebody.
Yeah,
I was in Costa Rica and uh,
we were down at this Ga,
this water,
it was the biggest waterfall I've ever seen.
It was like hundreds of feet high and Atlanta did in this lagoon,
this round lagoon and the water,
they told you don't go near the water.
And so there's these Japanese girls sitting on the edge.
They got their feet in and then one of them like jumps in and the water fucking
sucks her down immediately.
And I dove out.
I have,
I have a lifeguarding to Greg from when I was stoned and 16.
And so I dove into the water and I grabbed her and luckily I was checking them
out because they were these beautiful Japanese.
So I had my eyes on them.
And uh,
so I dive in and I grabbed,
I grabbed her and I pulled it to the surface.
I do the cross arm carry and I've pulled our polar out.
And you know what she did well,
just turned,
turned to her friends.
They all like console there.
Nobody said thank you,
I fucking saved her life.
So anyway.
Wow.
So there was these kids and the three,
you are jumping these lady.
How rude.
How bad.
A little shoddy got tall Japanese,
Japanese,
I think she was Japanese.
No,
no,
they were Japanese.
Japanese,
yeah.
She probably thought you were a lifeguard.
Yeah.
Probably thought that's what happened.
And then I,
and then I left and I'm with my family and,
uh,
they didn't see it happen,
so I was so fucking bummed.
Then we get to the parking lot and,
uh,
there's this busload of kids from some school and they had seen the whole thing
and they started chanting hero to me.
Oh.
And I said to my kids,
do you fucking see what's happening right now?
That's,
that's gotta be a great feeling.
Even if they didn't say thank you,
saved him.
I like,
it's what I do.
It's my job superhero.
You ever save anybody's life?
No,
I don't think so.
Not,
not directly.
Hmm.
Maybe you did this podcast.
Probably did.
I bet this people that have been suicidal that heard this and the cheer them up
ruined a few people too.
Let's be honest.
You don't listen to me.
I'm a fucking idiot.
What are you listening to me?
Because if people say I changed their life,
I was like,
okay,
if I accept it on the positive,
then I have to accept it on the negative too.
That's right.
No,
no.
You did it.
You did the whole thing.
Yeah.
You might've heard I said some shit that you enjoyed.
I'm very happy for that and I talked to some people that brought you some great
information.
I'm very happy for that too.
We're all in this together.
I'm not saving anybody.
Yeah.
Save yourself.
Don't listen to me.
Yeah,
call a hotline.
Yeah.
Listen and me,
don't take yoga.
Don't even do it.
Don't take it.
Don't listen to me.
I don't what the fuck I'm talking about.
Don't pick up archery.
What the fuck do you want to do?
You want to shoot arrows at things?
Get the fuck out of here.
Carbs.
Eat some fucking carbs.
Don't do Jujitsu.
You're going to get hurt.
You don't want to get hurt.
You're a 40 year old man.
We trying to choke people for stop it.
Don't listen to me.
Yeah,
don't eat elk.
Go Get a burger.
But we had an actual American hamburger.
Don't eat mushrooms.
Get outta here.
Just close your mind off.
Break your head.
They're going to break your head.
What did you go crazy like?
That guy from pink Floyd.
What if you go crazy?
What if you never come back?
But if you get antisemetic cause a judo,
but the thing is,
what if you do like for sure some people have smoked too much pot and blown a
fucking gasket,
let's be honest.
Right.
It has to have happen.
They say that actually they're finding,
my wife just told me this yesterday,
she read this article about people with schizophrenia are getting older and
they're smoking pot more because it's legal and uh,
they're finding people are coming in with a schizophrenia episodes from smoking
too much pot
that worst gets a phrenic or ready or became schizophrenia from the pot.
Not sure.
I think when you,
especially when you get too high,
it feels exactly like being crazy.
Yeah.
And I think when,
uh,
there's been moments for sure that I smoked too much pot and I freaked the fuck
out.
And,
uh,
when that happens,
it almost always feels like,
wow,
if I had to live life like this,
and it's one of the things that I tried to take any consideration when I,
when I think about people having something wrong with the way their brain
processes information or the way they talk is like thinking about how you feel
when you're on like a 200 milligram edible and you're like,
oh my God,
I just can't do this.
This is just too much.
Everything is anxiety and the freak out and life and death and all of your
memories pouring back into your head like a waterfall and you can't call them
circles.
They're spinning plates and all you want is for it to end please.
And a lie down here.
I hear when you take a shower,
it helps you get in the shower.
You're still freaked out.
If that was your whole life and you got to think what is,
uh,
what's your state of consciousness versus another person's?
You have to guess.
I don't,
I've never been in your mind.
I don't know how your mind works.
I have to guess that your mind is some reasonable,
it's got something like the way my mind works,
the way you look at life and we talk about so many things.
We agree on so many things.
I've got to think you're processing is very similar to mine,
but there's gotta be people out there where it's chaos where it's just like you
would the 200 milligram edible.
You're just like fuck all day.
It's just so like what,
who's who's doing that?
You know,
people do.
Just people watching the man from the is a building near us and just people
watching me like,
and they can't escape,
can escape the Kennys can't,
they're trapped in this is fucking constant snow ball effect of anxiety and
chaos.
And,
and you've got a wondered like what,
how much of that is brain chemistry?
How much of that is brain chemistry that's been adjusted by nature and by life
experiences and abuse and all these different factors that happen to people that
make them lose their grip.
All right.
So,
yeah,
I mean,
you see them on the street and he just,
you know,
there's a woman that is near my house.
She's at a bus stop and she's been at this bus stop for three years and I have
never,
and I pass her two or three times a day and I check,
I'm kind of obsessed with checking on her every time I drive by.
And uh,
she's never not been in that bus stop sitting down.
She's either reading or just under a blanket.
She's chain smokes.
I don't know where she gets a cigarettes.
She's got a cell phone.
Don't know how she charges it,
but I guess she goes to the bathroom at the gas station maybe.
Maybe people give her money and she goes,
doesn't beg,
doesn't engage,
just sits at this.
And it's a,
there's a,
she's in front of a gas station and a busy road.
It's,
it's the worst spot to say pouring rain.
She's out there cold winter.
She's out there.
It's crazy.
Wow.
Does the bus stop?
Have a cover?
Yeah,
but not,
not like,
uh,
the sides are not there.
Oh,
so on driving rain,
it's,
you know,
so she's just,
she's soaked.
Yeah.
And you see her talking to herself a little bit and you just think Jesus Christ.
And so I looked her up online,
I researched her and it turns out she's from Venice.
She went to Venice high and she's got a,
she's got parents in the neighborhood and they know she's there.
They can't get her to leave.
Social workers come by and they just realized she's happy there.
You know,
we're not happy but she's safe there.
Something about that spot maybe cause it's like the busiest spot round.
It makes her feel safe.
Wow.
Yeah.
Imagine that your kid,
I know.
Yeah.
As you kid blows a gasket and you got to let go at a certain point.
Fuck.
You can't make them take their medication after the age of 18 and for some
reason a lot of schizophrenia don't like taking their medication because of the
way it makes them feel.
God it man.
Okay.
What are the other options?
My think lithium is the main drug and then there's a couple other ones that
work.
Is there any behavioral therapy or physical therapy?
Oh yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
I think it's about replacing thoughts.
It's cognitive behavioral therapy.
They have to,
when they start thinking something,
they have to replace it with another thought and they have to train in that
until they can stop
the the voices.
But I,
but I think it's mostly medication.
Yeah.
I think we have an aversion to treating the brain the same way we treat other
things that get broken.
Yeah,
like a,
you know,
a few,
you have something wrong with your liver.
They,
they go,
Oh,
you've got liver disease.
Well we're going to give you medication for the liver.
Or there's something wrong with your brain.
Like,
are you sure?
You sure the sun,
right brain,
you know what's wrong,
right?
Like your brain's really not producing enough chemicals.
Is that it?
Or is it just the way you look at things?
No,
they look at it as a weakness.
Yeah.
That's all.
This is a weakness.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing.
It's a weird thing because sometimes it is,
sometimes people are weak,
but sometimes that's not it.
Sometimes there's something wrong.
And so if you are a person who's got something wrong and people were telling
you,
you just week,
they're like,
no,
this is fucked up.
Like this is this,
this is a terrible feeling and this is everyday for me all day.
Yeah.
There's just something wrong going on in there.
Like it has to be that there's variables to the way your brain works.
Just why,
like there's variables to the way your eyes function or any other part of your
body.
This is very,
I mean,
it just,
it's not equal.
Everybody doesn't get the same dose.
Right.
I mean,
depression is something that,
it's funny because I think I've asked you and you don't have depression.
And My,
my,
my buddy Mike Gibbons,
he's my best friend and we connect like you and me on everything.
But I have so much fucking depression that I,
I deal with it every day.
Yeah.
You know,
and I can't,
I have to meditate.
I got an exercise.
I,
I'm,
you know,
medicate everything.
Do you,
um,
what the,
well,
while you're injured right now,
you can't work out.
Right,
right.
And does that affect you when you take the time to help you?
Yeah.
I've been in a Rut,
if not exercising.
When you do exercise a lot,
does it alleviate your symptoms,
your feel?
Very
much.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm doing this thing now.
I think Neil Brennan recommended it and a magnet thing.
Yeah.
Tms.
Transcranial magnetic stimulation.
Yeah.
He said it was amazing.
I've done it for 10 weeks.
Every single day.
Really?
Yeah.
Just did it this morning.
Do you do it to yourself?
No.
You go in first,
you get an Mri and they map out your brain.
And the whole theory behind it is that they can use magnetic stimulation to sort
of like waking up one of the lobes in your brain that's associated with
depression.
And so you go in and first they map out your brain and then you go in and for
like a half hour,
they just pulse this magnetic thing onto your head.
It's like,
I'll very low grade MRI almost.
And uh,
I've had amazing results and it lasts forever.
You know,
you go through this cycle of it and then,
uh,
he's,
Neil's had the same experience.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Highly.
We're last forever.
Yup.
Well they say some people have to come in and,
and you know,
get a,
get a tuneup.
But generally it's one time.
Um,
there's a woman named Cat Zingano.
She's one of the UFC,
he's a top bantamweights and she,
uh,
fought UFC champion Amanda Nunez back in the day and actually beat her before
she won the title.
But in that fight she got hurt real bad and she talked about it on the podcast
that she developed a bunch of brain issues after that fight.
Cause like her cortisol levels were all fucked up at home unless we're all
fucked up.
She developed thyroid problem she had hit in the head.
So
she is,
yeah,
she couldn't keep weight off just trying to figure out what the fuck is wrong
with her.
And one of the things that helped her the best.
She talked about it really openly and in depth on the podcast.
But one of the things that helped her the best was they have this at the,
I think it's a different kind of magnetic therapy then this one,
cause I think this is only,
the center only exists around San Diego and a lot of military guys come back and
use it.
Football players,
people with head injuries and someone recommended it to her and it helped her
tremendously.
Yeah.
Really brought it back.
There's some real breakthroughs going on because um,
you know,
people are and they,
they,
you know,
they still use like electric shock therapy and it,
with,
with pretty good results but a lot of side effects.
Did you get hit in the head a lot when you were a kid?
Sometimes,
but did,
was there any like moments which get knocked down?
I don't think I ever got knocked out.
Did you ever get hit with a bat or,
I played hockey,
so I used to check people a lot.
Did you ever get down?
Did you get really hurt doing that?
Nah,
never that.
My neck,
my neck is still fucked up to this day from a,
from a check,
a head check that I made,
but now I don't think I ever had any concussions.
My friend mark,
no,
mine.
Mine.
Right.
Sorry.
My mind runs in the family.
My Mom,
my dad's got it.
It's,
it's,
it's very genetic depression.
No,
I'm sure it is is,
but I think it's accentuated by trauma.
Yeah.
And that's why I was asking you because,
uh,
even though you probably,
I mean,
I know you played a lot of hockey.
He knew the,
you probably don't think about it every time you collide and even falling down,
slamming into the wall.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that.
All that stuff rattles your brain.
Believe it or not.
People get concussions from getting hit in the chest sometimes.
Really?
Yeah.
Here's cats and gone.
No,
it says a EEG and vitals for my RM dams treats FDA approved to treat migraines.
Depression improves anxiety,
PTSD,
Tbi,
sleep,
ADHD,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Now,
accepting insurance and tri care mindset,
Rancho Bernardo,
check them out.
And this is a,
you can find this on cats and Ganos Twitter page.
She's got a picture of her with this apparatus on her head.
But I know it helped her.
Yeah,
I've heard of EEG.
It's,
it's really effective.
It helped her a lot.
He helped it.
Uh,
you know,
she could talk about what sparring was like before and afterwards.
So she just,
her coordination was off.
She was,
that's one of the things that happens to people when they get brain damage.
If they get knocked out or you know,
bad concussions is your,
your system's not firing correctly.
So you'll see their body's not moving right.
So it almost resets,
resets to hard,
dry,
damaged,
right.
You know,
the signals aren't getting to the muscles correctly.
So like you see,
one of the things that you see in older boxers when they've taken too many
horrible fights and they're,
they're really starting to lose it,
is there,
there steps look shorter,
their legs or look closer together.
They have it.
Oh,
they're having a harder time moving.
They don't have the confidence to have the balanced move around and they're
their,
their systems circuiting.
Yeah.
You know,
and you're seeing it in their coordination.
It's a weird thing to see too.
I've seen it in fighters where I remember them in their prime and then I see
them now and I'm like,
Whoa,
there's too,
it's two possibilities.
It could be an injury,
they could be dealing with an injury,
but if you find that there's no injury and like,
oh,
this is not good.
No,
just look at Ben Roethlisberger out there and the pocket when he,
he tries to run,
it's like little steps.
No movement in the shelters.
And that guy used to be fast back there,
but he's gotten hit a lot.
Does no getting away from it,
man.
It is what it is.
If you had a,
you ever been knocked out?
Yeah.
Not unconscious.
I've got stopped and a kickboxing match.
I got hit with a big left hook boom and my legs went out from under me.
It was crazy.
Well it didn't even hurt.
It was like like because you're,
you're full of adrenaline so you don't feel it in terms of like a ouchy.
It's not like [inaudible] but it's like,
it wasn't like a painful thing.
It was like being,
and then my legs just stopped working.
I was like,
Whoa,
what the fuck.
That was the hardest I ever been hit because it was just on the button.
It was a perfect Isaac Dwin.
I should,
as I was exhausted already at this third fight of a day in a kickboxing
tournament and just crank and my legs just went woopsies getting really lucky
with all the fighting you did that you never got knocked out.
Super Lucky.
But I definitely got hit in the head a bunch and even though I didn't get
knocked out,
there's a lot of sparring.
There was a lot of getting punched in the face.
There was a lot of getting kicked in the head.
Less kicked in the head,
believe it or not,
cause I was terrified.
I was always moving fast.
She wear helmets?
No,
we wear these things.
The first tournament's we used to wear these things on the back of the head and
that that was so when you get knocked out,
your fucking head doesn't bounce too hard off the ground.
I'm not bullshitting you pick one spot.
There's a video of me fighting with one of those on.
It's a video of me on youtube.
I've got this spot in the back of my head that it looks like a,
like a bald spot.
Like it would have if I had hair now,
but it's a Yamaka.
Yeah,
like a,
it's a red plastic thing.
It's hard to tell cause it's a shitty video.
But that red plastic thing was basically like a spongy thing that these to use
in taekwondo terms.
Cause we,
it was first it was no padding and then eventually they made,
people start wearing these helmets and they basically like these Cushnie helmets
that go over the top of the head and you've got to strap them out underneath.
See how that guy's wearing it.
The White Guy,
the see the guy in the background or the right side that's wearing the white
thing.
That's the standard one.
What I'm wearing.
Just a pat on the back of my head.
Right.
See that there's like a red thing in the back of my head,
but that's in case I got code because when we're fighting on a fucking,
this is a basketball court.
This is wood floor protection.
That was me knocking that guy out.
That was me.
This is me when I'm 19 so these,
this was where we fought all the time.
We always fought on hardwood floors.
One time I fought crazy way crazier from this.
Ready for this,
the bay state games.
I find the bay state games.
We fought on a tarp that was laid out over a cement floor.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I knocked a guy out in his head,
bounced off the cement.
Oh my God.
Kicked this dude in the head and his head bounced off some,
I'll never forget that sound.
Yes.
So I was 19 I didn't know what the fuck to do.
This is where the tournament was,
is okay.
It's okay.
We're going to do this.
We're going to fight here.
Like,
if that was today,
I would like,
are you guys out of your fucking mind?
I would.
I would be screaming if I went with my kid and he was supposed to fight in a
tournament and I got there and there was a thin plastic tarp stretch out over a
smooth concrete floor.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Are you crazy?
Yeah.
Like you need pads.
You need people to make sure they don't go out of bounds.
Tarp laid down over concrete.
Wow.
He was so,
so dangerous.
So I definitely got my noggin rattled.
Yeah,
a gang at times.
Yeah.
I don't know how many times
I said do a gymnastics for like six years.
Starting when I was like six backflip.
Oh yeah,
I could do,
I used to double backs.
No,
no,
I did.
I,
I trained for like six years.
Hard way.
How did I not know this?
Yeah,
so I used to do a,
yeah,
I could do round off,
back handspring into a double back.
And you still do that?
I can.
I haven't tried a single back in a while,
but I could do,
I could do standing back flips until a few years ago.
Wow.
Yeah.
No Shit.
Right.
That's so I,
so I just wanted to learn how to do that.
I did,
uh,
I over rotated a flip one time and I fucking slammed my head in a maths back
then.
When you see floor exercise today,
it's not even the same sport.
It's all
right with like two inches of padding.
Right.
When we did it,
it was those fucking rubber,
you know,
half inch thick mats that you've rolled out in the corners come popping up.
That's what we used to do it.
Oh yes.
You were fucking twisting your ankle all the time.
Landing on that shit.
How bad you fuck your head up when you landed.
It was bad.
My injuries or my ankles.
So I used to fuck up my,
yeah.
And then you know,
you can't,
then you can't do anything for a little while.
So,
well the reason why I keep asking you about head trauma is cause my friend Mark
Gordon,
he's an expert in traumatic brain injury.
He's an endocrinologist and he studies a lot of soldiers and he's written a
bunch of papers on um,
soldiers,
former football players,
fighters.
He's worked with a bunch of people that have had brain injuries and his
conclusion like,
and a lot of them that were suicidal,
a lot of them that are severely depressed.
And his conclusion is that for a lot of them,
what happened was damaged to the pituitary gland that stopped them from
producing hormones correctly.
And it leads to severe lack of energy,
depression.
And it's almost always correlated with head trauma and oftentimes head trauma
that people forgot about why they didn't think of that big of a deal.
But it could be literally wiping out on a jet ski slamming into the water game
and yeah.
And then you're fucked up for years and you don't know why.
Skiing for sure,
falling down,
hitting your head snowboarding is really common.
I've never snowboarded but apparently when the s the board kicks up,
your feet go up in the air and the fucking head comes down.
Yeah.
That's how people get got well,
and you got to wear a helmet.
Yeah.
And a lot of kids down.
Yeah,
I've heard of kids getting fucked up.
So yeah.
But so all those things contribute to the foot.
Your brain is super delicate,
you know,
it's really complicated machinery.
It's like when you drop your iPhone,
maybe you drop at once,
how many times you drop your iPhone dropped to three times today.
Hey,
hey,
put a fucking case on that thing.
Yeah,
I mean they of these drop tests,
right?
They do drop tests where they drop it over concrete and see how good it is.
Your head is similar in that you,
you can get away with getting racked in the head.
But I was in Hawaii recently and I dropped my phone the last time that,
you know,
you drop your phone and you know,
it's getting a little wonky and then you drop it the last time and it's just
gone.
It's gone.
Ceville it was just calling people.
I would,
I was smelling,
yeah,
I was showing a,
so when I was,
uh,
had the phone open and I was like,
watch,
it's on the context.
Like it's just going to start calling people and just started calling people and
I'd hang up and then would just call somebody else,
hang up and it would just cost wheels.
It was just falling apart.
It wouldn't let me log in anymore.
Like it wasn't,
it wasn't sensing my fingers touching the screen to put in the key code.
Who's your shit all backed up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was all backed up,
but it was like,
God dammit.
Yup.
Yeah.
I smashed my screen.
I didn't,
I didn't give a fuck your heads like that.
That's my point.
Your heads like that.
Like if I didn't get that one last drop,
maybe a phone would've been all right.
Yeah.
They would've kept that phone today.
You know,
maybe be able to look through the new phones.
We,
I don't need that.
It's basically the same phone,
right?
Nope.
Draak smack.
I'm reading this book now about,
um,
speaking of changing your brain,
it's called a how to change your mind.
God is Michael Pollan.
Yeah.
He's been on the podcast talking about,
oh,
no shit.
Yeah.
Did he talk about his new book,
about the,
um,
it,
it's,
it's basically about,
uh,
um,
psychedelics and LSD and mushrooms in particular,
and it traces the whole fucking history of it.
I had no idea how much research was done back in the fifties and sixties.
I mean,
they had conclusive studies that were showing with,
um,
alcoholism.
People were 70% of people that underwent these treatments with psychedelics got
sober,
you know,
depression,
cigarettes,
cigarettes.
I mean,
it's amazing.
And all that shit just got fucking thrown away.
Corrupt people kept that information away from folks.
The studies that Nixon funded,
like Nixon funded a bunch of studies that showed positive benefits of marijuana.
How is that?
Right.
And they,
you know,
the Nixon administration just fucking Canva.
I get out of here with this shit not releasing this.
Well,
and the,
the other thing he mentioned is that it got squashed by,
by shrinks because they had a vested interest in people not going into the woods
for a weekend and coming back without their depression.
So yeah.
So they,
so they disqualified all the studies.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
What psychiatrists were like,
horrified that there was the,
these kind of results were coming back.
Was it that for sure?
Or was it people who've never taken psychedelics horrified that people are out
there experimenting with their consciousness?
Because I think a lot of these psychiatrists are probably really straight laced
guys.
And so in their mind,
especially in the shadows of reefer madness and all the propaganda that they'd
heard in the 30s and forties and when you look at those people and they're out
there in the fucking desert or wherever they're going dancing around and taking
mushrooms under the moonlight,
you like,
they're blown their brains out here.
You've got to stop this.
If they're straight laced people that have ever done psychedelics,
they might not be in cahoots.
It might more likely be a bunch of people to think it's a fucking terrible idea
to let people run around taking acid.
Well there was just some of the medical journals came out with,
with pieces saying that none of these studies are valid because there wasn't a,
I forget what it is about studies that have to be consistent.
Um,
but the other thing is it was political and you had Timothy leary who is,
you know,
the worst thing to happen to this kind of testing because he was saying was it
dropped dropout in turn on drop,
drop out.
And that whole idea they said,
you know,
people taking LSD are not going to fight your wars.
And so that became a threat to the status quo.
Wow.
And that's when the law is started to come out.
Huh.
It's interesting
cause you also got a lot of people to get excited about it,
right?
Yeah.
But got
he took it away from it being a,
um,
a medical process and he made it about,
you know,
enlightenment,
but in a kind of fluffy spiritual way.
Well he made it a big movement.
Right.
I think you saw that he was probably going to change the world with that
movement.
Yeah.
He kind of did.
It definitely had a big impact.
You know,
all those people that took acid.
It's like,
think about if you really stop and think about apple and you really look at the
fact that apple,
Steve Jobs said that taken acid was like one of the greatest things that ever
happened to him.
Yeah.
That was,
as it was famously talked about it.
And who knows what a,
what an impact that had on him deciding to start apple and what would an impact
apple has had and the technology world.
Oh No.
And talks about it in the book.
He draws a straight line from people starting to take all this stuff because it
was happening in Silicon Valley.
This whole psychedelic movement was like right in that area.
And he says that it,
you know,
Bill,
Bill Gates apparently took it once,
but that all those guys were coming in and they were,
you know,
they,
there were these people that would lead.
There was a guy named,
um,
uh,
no Hubbard,
well,
Ron doss has mentioned also,
but there was a guy name Hubbard who was really like,
you know,
a corporate version of LSD.
He was going to companies and he was taking the CEOs of companies and taking
them in for these three day drop acid experiences.
Wow.
Corporate acid.
Well,
they're kind of doing that at burning man.
How is that?
Right?
Some corporations,
I mean not a lot,
but there's some cool companies and go to burning man.
Yeah.
You know
what's this?
Alfred?
Matthew Hubbard.
He's an early proponent of the drug LSD.
During the 1950s he is reputed to be the Johnny Appleseed of Lsd and the first
person to emphasize led lsds potential as a visionary or trends and dental
truck.
But this guy had an a fucking life.
Somebody's got to do a movie about his life.
He,
he was like working for the government.
He was a double agent.
He was,
while he was dropping acid,
he was,
he started with nothing now I think before,
before,
during and after.
He had like eight different careers and he was like a spy and he bought it.
He started with nothing and ended up with like a bunch of airplanes that he was
leasing out,
became a millionaire and then spent it all trying to educate people on Lsd.
He was worth like tens of millions of dollars and he ended up broke at the end.
Wow.
Yeah.
All for the LSD,
he believed in it so strongly that said it was going to change the world and it
would have,
it may still now there's,
now it's coming back.
Well,
there was a hiccup or several
generations had a pass before people started understanding that there's,
there's,
there's a risk to everything.
There's a risk to sports.
There's a risk to every fucking thing you do driving your cars at risk.
There's a risk with psychedelics,
but there's also a reward.
And I think if you're going to be honest,
do you have to look at both of them?
You have to look at the potential risk.
You have to look at the reward and they're not looking at the reward to try to,
there's too many people out there that are trying to deny the reward and you got
to find out why.
And in this day and age,
it might be a conspiracy.
It might be some pharmaceutical industry that doesn't want it to be legal
because it would undermine their profits.
It might be,
it might be some law enforcement unions that think it's a bad idea to make less
things illegal.
It take,
you know,
prisons.
Yeah.
It will take people away,
you know,
in terms of the amount of people that they need for the job.
It'll,
you know,
which I think that's another story.
But when you
and people look at that kind of stuff and you look at like the,
the underlying sort of patterns that we follow in this country,
you know,
the patterns that we like,
are you happy or not happy with the way things go,
the way things are run?
In what sense?
Just in any sense in all of it.
Yeah.
I trust that we do have the best system out there and we challenge it every day.
And I still think that we live in a place where the tenants of our society are
in place for sure they swing one way or the other.
But I still believe in democracy and um,
I think the internet as an as an overall thing has been positive for people
getting their voices out and for,
for information period
being distributed.
But the I,
the idea that we're faced with that in this day and age,
there's grown adults telling other grown adults what they can and can't put in
their body.
Yeah.
And then not being honest about the benefits.
Right.
That's where it gets squirrely.
That's where the whole thing falls apart.
Like you're just a guy.
Like if you and I are the only two people on the planet and he only came out,
I'm not going to let you take that acid.
Like why?
Well,
because it's illegal.
Look,
I wrote it down.
Can you take the acid?
Right.
Well that would be preposterous.
Yeah.
But somehow or another,
it works.
When there's a million people,
then a person could tell you,
you know,
if you're a fucking grown adult,
you can't tell me what I can take that stupid.
Yeah.
If,
if you can't prove beyond a shadow of a doubt that what I'm going to take is
going to fuck with you.
If you can't prove that,
then stop.
Yeah.
Look,
if someone does something,
if takes something and does and they take PCP and they run phase first through a
fucking seven 11 window that's on them,
it's on their actions.
It doesn't mean you shouldn't be able to try PCP and I don't think you should
try PCP.
I think when enough enough people smashed through windows and go crazy,
you go,
hey,
maybe that's a drug I should fucking avoid.
But that's how you find out about that.
Yeah.
You let grown adults make their own decisions and if you're the one who's making
the decisions for all the grown adults,
you better have some real fucking logic to what you're saying.
It turns out they don't,
and this is the same society that allows the pharmaceuticals to peddle opiates
to people for the last 30 years saying that it was the greatest thing you could
do.
Exactly.
I think it's good that they make money because they make medicine that helps a
lot of people.
They're not all bad.
I think in general,
pharmaceuticals have helped people in tremendous ways,
but you can't deny that if there's some way,
shape,
or form that people are influencing other people having access to beneficial
things because it would impact their profit line.
That's,
that's evil,
that's evil.
You have a lot of fucking money.
If you really going out of your way to hire lobbyists to make sure that
mushrooms don't get on the table,
come on,
man.
You're,
you are,
you're a fucking real problem.
That's a real problem.
If you look at Yin and Yang,
this is,
this is the,
uh,
opposing forces that were battling to try to get total complete freedom of your
consciousness.
These are the opposing forces.
Their ignorance,
like these psychiatry,
I guarantee you these psychiatrists were worried about correlations between
psychotic episodes and psychedelic drug use and they're worried about people
falling apart and they're right.
They're right.
This are the ones that wanted to get it.
Illegal debt,
right?
It's like working on backflips when there's a fucking thin pad under you.
Yeah.
You could fall on your head.
You're right.
And we say,
don't do gymnastics.
People fall on their head.
One out of 10 falls on their head.
You're not doing chimney,
not falling on your fucking head.
Right,
right.
This is the same thing.
It's the same thing.
So people worried about it that don't really have experience in it.
I guarantee you most of those psychiatrists just didn't have experience in it or
we're super cautious folks is if they did have experiences with it,
maybe they try a little mushroom dose and they'd be like,
wow,
this is amazing.
His brain and also controlling,
um,
you know,
set and setting.
They keep talking about,
you know,
and realizing that the,
the occurrence of a psychotic episode is so much lower when it's,
you know,
when you're,
when it's being dispensed the right,
right.
Yeah.
So much lower.
You ever been led through it by somebody now when you did Iowasca was there like
a guy,
Wasco DMT.
My friend Aubrey acted as a,
he co signed to like set the setting.
Um,
in a way where it was,
you know,
I would,
I would say like spiritual,
like not dot Riddick not over the top,
but just announcing your intentions that we're going into this,
we're going into this,
we're going to let go.
We're going to,
you know,
give thanks to all,
all the spirits around us and all the energy around us.
Just go into this with a good intention.
Give,
be grateful.
Be uh,
go into it with gratitude.
And then the way it hits you,
it hits you like,
like a infinite cyte clone of geometric patterns in impossible colors.
Just blasting in your brain instantaneously.
And you'll have
going into it with the intention of letting go is probably one of the best
pieces of advice you could give people to avoid a freak out,
right?
Go with it.
Let it go.
Just let yourself go.
And it's what it's trying to do is your ego is trying to wrestle with this
grizzly bear,
this enormous short face.
Bear on steroids is trying to,
your ego is trying to wrestle with this impossible to resist force.
And that's what leads to a lot of people freaking out.
So Iga,
losing your ego is the ultimate goal of it.
Um,
I don't think anybody ever really loses or ego.
I think you,
you keep it in check,
you lose some of it.
You keep some of it because that's what's part of your survival mechanism.
The real problem is like having a healthy ego.
You know,
like,
uh,
like if your wife looks good and she's looking at herself in the mirror,
she was like,
I look good.
You look fucking great.
I do look good.
Like she feels good.
It feels everybody that's ego,
right?
You want to know you,
you look good,
but it's not a bad ego.
It's fun.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
The real problem is when it gets out of control and toxic,
then it looks like other people see it.
And like if you,
you know,
you see gross,
just gross behavior,
grow selfishness,
you see that and you go,
oh,
that's the bad part of the ego.
That's what I'm seeing.
Yeah.
But the key is to know which is which.
And that's hard.
It's hard to know which is which,
which one is the overwhelming force inside your mind?
Which one is the one that's controlling your consciousness and your behavior and
which is,
is it the good ones,
the bad one?
Is it the fun healthy one or is it the one that is a,
you know,
completely obsessed with yourself and only yourself?
Yeah.
You don't know until you have these experiences and then the,
the,
the nature of them gets exposed.
You'd like takes him down to the roots and you start thinking about,
well where did all this come from?
Like where is it?
Where's all,
what's the source of all this?
Like,
oh there's a validation issue.
There's a this issue,
there's a trust issue,
there's a,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's swirling out of that in this a unnatural form to create the negative
behavior that you are manifesting in your life.
Like it,
all of it comes from something.
And one of the things about psychedelic experiences is it shut it like it shuts
the ego off for a second and lets you stand outside of and go look at the things
new.
You look at this thing,
things,
grubs and alia,
it doesn't work.
You know like here's,
here's the PR for example,
ego.
That doesn't work.
Name dropping.
Like if you're hanging out with someone and he's like,
yeah,
you know Sean Penn was over my house last night.
Man,
I'm fucking in Ely.
No.
You know what Jeremy Pivot was just telling me about that last week.
Name dropping skinny,
why that name?
But like it doesn't really work but everybody knows your name dropping and I'll
be like,
yeah,
what?
I'm Steven Spielberg and are pretty tight.
Like yeah.
But it's one thing like if you told me you went over Sean Penn's house,
I'd be like,
oh,
what's he like?
Like then it wouldn't be name dropping.
Like if you did it,
it wouldn't be namedropping.
Like if you told me like I was hanging out with Cha with Sean Penn and I'd be
like,
oh,
how weird.
Well because it's the beginning of a story.
Yeah.
I'm not just going to let that,
let that hang is a followup.
Yeah,
that's not your whole thing.
Yeah.
Right.
So like comedy is like name dropping with stories,
good stories that go with it.
But you know,
there are comedians that are really like guileless about just bringing a name in
or bringing up a project they worked on and you look back at the joke and ego
could have told that joke without telling me that a Frank Sinatra was in the
audience that night.
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah.
And I remember Anthony Clarke used to do that when he was coming up in Boston.
He was the guy,
he was the guy,
the young hot guy in Boston,
dude.
And I mean that dude,
you put his name on a marquee and he was fucking one year out of college and he
was this cute guy with a southern accent and the base of El cap on.
And he was silly and he would fill up a fucking room and he would just,
and then he started to get some success and it always found his way in his act.
He would talk about it.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
I was talking to this act or when I was doing Chicago on Broadway and,
no,
not Chicago.
What,
what did he do?
Oklahoma,
he did Oklahoma on Broadway when he was like 24 years old and you know,
and then he just started and he got in with that with the river Phoenix and he
did like three river Phoenix movies and he was fucking good.
And then somehow,
uh,
he got into the TV route and didn't follow the filmer,
but he's,
he's a good actor.
Yeah.
I remember he had Boston common number that Boston common and that didn't go,
it went for a little while,
but it got canceled and it was a show that was all his right.
And then he went to do.
Yes dear.
They did?
Yes dear for a long,
long time.
No.
Then he did one with Dan Akroyd.
Oh,
he did?
Where Dan Aykroyd was a priest.
I maybe they were both priests.
Really?
Yeah.
That might've been af cause cause a yes dear was on for a good seven,
eight years.
Easily.
Forever.
Yeah.
Soloman Soloman.
Soloman.
Huh?
So that dude and his,
his quote per episode was very high from the get go and he just kept buying real
estate.
Well done.
That's what he does know.
Right?
I haven't,
I haven't talked to him in a while.
I think I heard he sells real estate.
No.
Yeah,
I was like Anthony,
he was a murderer or back in Boston and we used to see him at Faneuil hall and
you'd fill that fucking place,
you know the comedy connection when they moved,
when Bloomin' right.
Took over and they moved to the big room and they moved out of that little tiny
room and put it in Faneuil hall.
I remember walking through there one day and Anthony Clark was murder and,
and I was like,
this is 90% women.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
At least,
right.
It's all women.
Yeah.
Dude,
I'll come and see him.
Guys loved them too.
Don't get me wrong.
But women really loved him.
He was so cute,
you know.
Well,
they say that's the secret to being a draw is appeal to women because they're
the ones that decide what to do it.
Yes.
Yeah.
Right.
Like there's not a whole lot of chicks begging to go to slayer.
And if they are,
take them.
That's it.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
They want to go see someone cute.
I bet this like probably a disproportionate number of chicks going to see aqua
man.
I bet.
If you allow,
yeah.
If you looked,
if you looked at the number of women that want to go see a superhero movie and
uh,
the number of women that want to go see aqua man.
Yeah.
It's off the charts.
Aqua man's favor.
Someone should do a study.
That's a handsome man.
Well,
he's his name.
Jason Momoa.
He was Badass.
Game of Thrones.
He's a beast to super nice guy too.
I met that guy in a whole foods and nail sweetheart,
sorta telling you,
oh sweetheart.
He is like,
you're so handsome.
It's confusing.
So call and beautiful and [inaudible] feelings,
right?
Yeah.
Leave that guy.
My wife said it best.
She said he's everybody's type.
She's like,
you know some girls,
Brad Pitt's there type.
You know some girls it's uh,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Yeah.
Some girls just Jimmy Fallon.
He's everybody's tight
and he's a giant and he's got awesome tattoos.
The fucking Nice Guy.
Fucking fuck.
Are those his real tattoos?
I don't believe so.
I think that's just for aqua man.
That's his tattoos for aqua man.
What are his real tattoos?
He's got a gang of real tattoos.
The forearm ones.
I think this is real tattoos.
Yeah.
Boy,
that takes some time and makeup because if he's doing a role where they don't
want that,
that's a lot of time covering that shit up every day.
I think they have to cover up shit with him.
Yeah,
it was just that,
that beautiful face.
Get on screen that all those damp and panties do the talk and
see you again tomorrow,
man.
Whew.
Yeah.
Girls are going to that movie.
It's like a crane.
It's like a porn theater in Times Square in the 70s for women's.
Probably like slipping there,
hands down,
moisture in the air and yourself off all these little heaters.
When you're walking at cheaters,
your feet are stuck on the floor.
You think it's the popcorn butter?
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
Yeah.
Um,
how do we get on subject to him,
aqua man
girls deciding what to go see it,
right?
Yeah.
Girls would be,
they'd be like,
yeah,
let's go see aqua man.
You'd be like,
wait a minute though.
You hate superhero movies,
whatever you want to go.
Yeah.
She wants to stare at tasting them all off.
You're right.
He is pretty beautiful.
We watched him on screen,
dammit.
Yeah.
Shit.
Can't hate her.
He thinks some lemon.
Watch MMA for that reason.
I think some guys are cute.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Not only cute,
but savages.
Right?
I mean the number of women with a
sketchy childhoods that are attracted to MMA fighters off the charts.
Yeah.
I want to say that in a very polite way is pled as I could say.
I think even regular women,
I think like lawyers,
like buttoned down women see a cause there are ran neutered men all day.
Yeah.
You're around a guy like you know Luke Rockhold is no,
it might be better.
Look in the Jason Ma and he's a UFC.
He was middleweight champion.
Beautiful.
Six foot three,
six foot four,
somewhere in that range.
Plan features looks like a model.
Handsome was fuck God.
I want to say hell yeah.
Ass Kicker.
That's not the best picture of him,
Bro.
That's kind of gets,
that's after I've seen before.
If it's a beast,
but point is uh,
there's Garol and t go that one above what?
The blue shorts on.
What you see is a look at that handsome bastard.
Look at him.
Yeah.
He's got a good build.
That's the kind of build my wife likes.
She doesn't like it too big.
Shakes likes like me and him slow down.
You and him are the same.
The fuck
I just short girls are watching that guy though.
Like,
okay,
here's another one.
George Saint Pierre hundred percent.
Look at that beautiful body.
Oh yeah.
George Saint Pierre is beautiful.
Like George Saint Pierre Literally has to beat women away from them
because they're five from me.
I'm busy.
I am busy.
Go to that picture up there.
We're just throwing a punch.
The one right there.
Look at that.
I mean you don't think girls would be begging to have that inside of them.
I was a woman.
If I was a heterosexual woman and I saw that guy and he was like,
would you like a drink?
I'd be like,
fuck yes,
I'd like a drink.
Yeah.
God Damn you savage.
Let's do this.
Yeah,
I want to drank.
Can we have it after you?
Fuck me.
Yeah.
I don't want to get too drunk.
I want to feel it still.
Woo.
Yeah,
and they go after it.
The I or some of the players?
Some of the fighters.
Oh,
I don't want to talk about that.
How dare you kiss and tell,
but it's when other thing is interesting is female fighters.
Right?
That I was reading a story about a husband who's white,
who's a trainer,
I think,
and his wife was a boxer and I was reading the story about him,
like his experience,
like bringing her to the ring,
like getting her,
his wife is in there and she's going to knuckle up with some other chicken shit
and maybe get really fucking hurt.
Yeah.
And to be there while this is all happening.
That's a wild,
that's a wild life.
A female fighter is a wild creature.
You gotta think of male fighter.
It's like almost all boys,
somewhere in the back of their head have this ridiculous fantasy of being able
to fuck everybody up.
Like,
come on bitch.
You know,
fight a bunch of people like Goddamn Chuck Norris Movie Karate Kick People.
That would be cool.
It's just the reality of learning how to do that.
It's like,
oh,
I don't want to do that.
That's too much.
It's too dangerous to scare.
Fuck this.
And most people don't do it.
But for women to have that,
it's probably way more rare to have this desire to secretly fuck people up.
Probably way more rare.
Maybe like,
let's be generous and say 20% of the,
the number that men would want to fuck people are maybe 20% of that is like the
number that would be women.
So then how many of them go through with it?
Yeah.
How many of them go through with it and get to be like a cat Zingano or get to
be like an Amanda Nunez like Jesus Christ.
If that number is so small,
so small in terms of like general population,
those are some wild humans.
Yeah.
If they get to that stage where they're fighting in a fucking cage for a living,
whoa.
Yeah.
Someone like Holly Holm,
like that is a crazy way to make a living.
Yeah.
Now you've got to think if they make it that far,
they're even more vicious than men because they've,
they've,
you know,
they,
there's such a social taboo for them.
For men,
it's like,
oh,
that's bad ass.
You're an MMA fighter.
But for women,
everybody just thinks it's weird and they think there's something wrong with
you.
Well,
it's become more acceptable,
but it's still terrifying,
especially for men that don't train,
like to wait for a man who doesn't train and he's like around Misha Tate,
she's really hot.
And she had also fucked people.
Like,
Ooh,
yeah.
They get weirded out.
Like imagine that girl could fuck you up like she's hot and she could fuck you
up.
That's not nice.
Some guys probably love that.
People like that bondage with are tied up and overpowered.
But what are the odds that a girl who knows what the fuck people up is looking
for?
That kind of guy at almost zero.
Yeah,
that's true.
Those girls,
it doesn't line up Luke Rockhold to in and get stuff by another alpha.
That would be a good porn movie.
Right.
Shit,
I would go for day to do his bank.
It like Luke Rockhold,
you chew a lot of porn in bank and then have it released after he's retired from
his career.
Yeah.
You know,
cause right now it's just going to get in the way.
Yeah.
It's going to be a distraction,
but he knows that's his 401k my porn.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
it's uh,
the numbers of women that become elite fighters.
W I wonder what it is in terms of like the amount,
the try it and then the amount that become fully successful.
I bet it's a tiny,
tiny percentage like to get all the way through.
Like how many,
like how many men,
when you,
when you were growing up,
how many,
uh,
either wanted to learn how to box or wrestle or do some kind of
a lot of wrestlers.
Yeah.
I mean it was a school sport.
There was taekwondo and there was wrestling.
Those were pretty much the only forms that I,
that I saw.
We didn't have boxing in my town,
but a lot of kids you knew were into it,
right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
How many girls?
I can't think of any.
Super rare,
but the martial arts classes did have a lot of girls.
It's kind of interesting.
It was a good number.
It wasn't half,
but it might've been 20%.
Yeah.
It might be 20% women that were in those classes cause they wanted to learn self
defense,
you know?
Okay.
I put my daughter in taekwondo just she wasn't that into it,
but I go just do a year.
Just to give you some sense of facing somebody if a fight happens.
Yeah,
and some sense of what it's like to struggle with someone physically there
moving.
You've got to move with them.
You got to,
the older you are,
when you start learning that,
the more difficult it is to incorporate it into your,
the way you think about things.
Right.
I think when you're young,
if you have some experience with martial arts,
you'll be more calm and confident if something happens when you get older.
Right.
You're already your bodies.
You develop knowing how to move that way.
Yeah.
When you were already like kind of set in your ways and you're injured and
you're old and then someone wants to teach you a wheel kick,
like,
oh Christ.
Yeah.
I like this.
No way my body's going to do that.
My body has move like that.
Yeah.
It's like you being able to do backflips click.
You could still do a back load your body,
learn how to do that when you were young.
Yup.
It gets in there that programs in there
and there's a,
there's a moment of faith when you do a back flip where when you go up you have
to go up before you go back.
And that's the first mistake and the constant mistake is people,
people go to do a backflip and they lunge backwards and they land in their head,
but you really have to trust that you have to shoot your hands up,
not back,
and then you pull it in,
go over damn scary.
And that's like that with the,
yeah.
I'm sure with martial arts is this moves it or does a moment of faith.
When I don't,
I mean for a long time then I tried to do a a turning side kick on the heavy
bag.
There's like a moment like,
okay,
I'm going to hit this thing.
Right.
What am I doing here?
Yes.
Okay.
Ready and turn watch drops off.
Oh,
I just dropped.
It's big ass knife.
Shit.
That's not good to have around right there.
What am I 12 keep this big giant knife on the table.
But yeah,
when I,
when I do it today,
to this day,
I have to do it slow a couple of times and get the feel of it.
Yeah,
I haven't trained in a while and then then,
then it becomes a normal thing.
Right.
But man,
it's hell on your fucking knees.
I got a new knee thing going on,
like the Za the third time I've had to get stem cells injected into this
meniscus tear.
I got to school really?
Hey,
this little tiny meniscus tear and it develops into assist.
Uh,
the,
the tear,
we've hit it with stem cells a few times and it doesn't give me any pain
anymore,
but assist keeps developing in that area and it assists,
has to get punctured and drain is getting smaller and smaller.
It happened three different times or how to get it drained.
And the last time was a few days ago and it was the smallest it's ever been,
but still fucking annoying.
But you're still running.
Yup.
It doesn't hurt when you run.
I'm taking time off right now and taking a little bit of time off right now.
I'm going to tell you a couple of weeks off and a,
I'm going to run at a slower pace,
skip the dog some exercise,
and I'm going to be more just more cautious about it.
Not going to push myself.
I'm trying to figure out what it is I'm doing that's causing this sis to recur.
I think it's just overall pounding of the,
the hill running,
kicking the bag and all that shit.
Yeah.
I need to,
uh,
let it fully set in before I go back to doing that shit.
So I'm just doing a bunch of other different stuff.
Now.
A lot of yoga is the cryogenics help.
Um,
it'll help someone,
you know,
what would cryogenics is really good for is first of all,
it's really good for your mood.
Uh,
if you've never done it before,
the best kind are the kind where you get your whole body in there,
not just your neck down the neck.
Down is okay.
It's definitely better than nothing,
but the real feeling is when your head's under and your whole body is like
immersed in this air that's cooled by liquid nitrogen,
it's fucking for raising.
Dude have,
you've done it now,
today.
Let's do it today.
He,
I'll do it.
We'll do it today.
Okay.
We can do it today.
You're going to love it.
It's,
it's a freak out man.
It's a freak out.
How long did you stay in?
40 minutes.
And then I stay out for 10 minutes and then I do another three minutes.
Damn.
Yeah.
You feel amazing afterwards and they'll fix my knee.
Well,
won't fix it.
It'll reduce inflammation now.
But norepinephrine,
that's what it's called,
right?
Is that the word?
Sure.
Um,
that stuff gets radically boosted in your brain.
It helps a lot of people with arthritis.
A lot of people have,
um,
a lot of inflammation.
It helps him is that I say I said it right.
Um,
it ramps that shit up.
You feel so good when you get out of there like woo.
It lasts a while to,
ah,
you're just freezing to death.
You are freezing to death.
You are on your way to death.
And he stepped out of it and you're like,
wow.
And it just,
everything just feels,
yeah,
it feels good man.
It feels good.
Yeah,
I saw him.
I fucking love swimming in cold water.
It's amazing for you the way you feel when you get out too.
But here's the thing,
um,
it's not the best thing to do if you're trying to gain muscle weight.
You have to wait a while after the exercise.
Like there's apparently there's,
there's a bunch of different studies and I know Andy Galpin has been involved in
a bunch of these studies and Rhonda,
Patrick has discussed some of this research as well.
But what,
uh,
what happens is there's a window of time after you lift weights.
We,
you should just leave your body alone and not ice anything and that this is more
beneficial to gaining strength and explosiveness and mass and stuff like that.
But that after a window of time,
then it's beneficial to get into the fro the ice bath or to do cryo or something
like that.
But you want to give yourself your body a period of time to physiologically
adjust to the work.
Like your body knows what's happened.
Oh,
Greg did dead lifts today.
Okay.
We got all the way to get everything in place,
get it.
But if you freeze it right there,
then it has an effect on the overall,
and I might be butchering this,
but I think it has effect on the overall amount of gains that you can make.
Okay.
Because your body's not sending the chemicals to the,
the way it would see if you could find out.
That's true.
Um,
that's uh,
figured out how to Google that one.
How do you agree with that one?
Yeah.
Post workout,
um,
cryo therapy and hypertrophy cause that's what they're,
that's what they're trying to uh,
Dick,
they were trying to figure out whether or not it's beneficial or not in that
case.
So they think that it's really good for the mood and it's really good for people
with joint issues.
A lot of the folks that go there,
they have like a back surgery or back issues and it gives them a lot of relief.
And you can do it every day too.
Cause it's only three minutes.
The thing about something like that is it's not,
it's not like any other kind of therapy.
Like,
you can't do it any longer.
It's not like you're being a pussy because you're only doing it for three
minutes.
Bitch.
You can't even do three minutes the first time you go in there at two minutes,
you're like,
fuck this.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Two minutes.
You're probably ready to bail,
but then your body will get used to it and then you can do three minutes.
But it's a,
it's very controversial,
especially because a woman died.
There was [inaudible] Vegas.
Yeah.
A woman in Vegas was operating it herself and uh,
apparently she was not in the right height and the liquid nitrogen was getting
into her,
her lungs.
She was breathing it in and she passed out and she passed out and froze to
death.
Wow.
Yeah.
Terrifying.
They,
she had,
uh,
again,
I think the story was that she had worked there and you know,
she was after hours just doing therapy on herself and she fucking fell asleep in
there.
He should never do that by herself.
If you do it at a reputable place.
So always be someone standing by watching while you're in.
They stand outside the door.
While you're inside of it.
It's scary though,
because you realize when you're in there,
you're like,
this is a,
this is something you can't survive for that long.
You can survive it for a few minutes,
but you're literally exposing yourself to something that is 100% fatal if you
stay in it.
Yeah,
no,
it's like cold water.
You don't have to be in freezing cold water.
They say the amount of hours you can survive in water is like surprisingly warm.
Yeah.
It fits.
Like in the forties,
you can die after a couple hours.
I'm throwing numbers out,
but
not surprising that getting wet is one of the most dangerous things that can
ever happen to you if you were in the winter in the mountains.
Yeah.
It's one of the most dangerous things.
We fall into water.
They actually have a rewarming drills that they teach people,
particularly soldiers and a outdoorsman that are interested in this shit.
My friend John Barklow,
uh,
he works for Sitka.
That's a premier outdoor company.
They make 'em like hunting clothes and stuff like that and they have a whole
video on how to do a rewarming drill.
And so what he does,
his,
him and his friend jump into a frozen river and then go into a tent and heat
themselves back up again.
Do Dude,
you watch this and your,
your whole body just goes,
ah,
cause you there in the winter and the jump into a river,
they've got to move the ice around and hop in this fucking frozen stream and
they go all the way under and then they come out with their soaked down and all
their,
they're soaked wool clothes and they're soaked synthetics and they get into a
tent,
the climate,
their sleeping bags and they try to heat themselves up.
If you have,
yeah,
if you have no access to,
uh,
a building,
a house,
no shower,
no,
you're fucked.
You're out in the woods.
There's very specific things that you have to do in order to survive.
If you don't follow the right steps,
you absolutely will die.
Yeah.
It's really common to kills more people than probably anything in the woods
freezing to death.
Yeah.
That movie revenant freaked me out just going into the woods up north for three
months to collect pelts and you're walking through fucking streams and it's
pouring rain and he got no heat or no electricity.
Fuck that.
Yeah.
That's how people died.
Lots of people live that way too.
A lot of people live that way until they died.
I mean that.
Do you think about those people that made it across this country and the people
like Lewis and Clark and all of these pioneers that just didn't even know what
the fuck was around the next corner and they just walked on through with what
they have like donkeys with shit on their back.
How much food you have?
Yeah.
Do you even know what the fuck you're going?
He hit an impasse.
You,
you hike for miles and then you come up to a mountain and you got to double back
and go around Christ.
No Google Earth,
no nothing.
Shit.
Maps and dog shit maps written by people you hope knew what the fuck they were
talking about.
Right.
You know,
he'd get maps from native Americans,
get maps from a sailor and try to figure it out,
and then you randomly go into the wrong territory and a Indians want to kill
you.
You know,
there's an interesting,
a film that's out on Netflix right now,
the ballot of Buster Scruggs,
Colin's great movie,
and it's all about that.
It's all about the old west.
It's really weird,
man.
It's so weird.
They're the weirdest guys of all time.
It turns away the Kahn brothers.
Yeah.
Big Lebowski.
You one of my all time favorites.
They've just made so many cool,
weird,
but this one's
really weird.
It's like a bunch of non connected stories.
I thought they were connected,
but they're not.
They just all taking place in the same time period and it's called the old west
and the end pretty similar late.
They're all fucking dark and you got to go.
Go into it.
I would highly recommend it,
but go into it knowing it's going to be fucking dark.
You've got to go there.
Just accept it.
But Tom waits his one is fucking amazing.
Yeah,
Dude.
Amazing.
Yeah.
I thought it was Dick [inaudible] for a second.
Oh yeah.
Is that it's multi,
right?
Dude is so good.
Okay.
That one.
That one was really good that the singer guy who was really good.
I love that he,
well,
I don't want to spoil it.
I don't want to spoil it,
but now it's,
yeah,
they're all,
they're all great,
but at the end of it I was like,
what the fuck did I just watch?
Yeah.
Did you ever watch the deadwood?
They live on Hbo.
I never did.
I never saw that
it,
the thing about deadwood is I watched it once and they were swearing so much
that my bullshit alarm went off.
That's why I stopped watching.
Yeah.
It was like,
I don't think people talk like that back then.
Yeah,
because they didn't talk like that in the 50s and the 60s see like the trend
doesn't make sense.
If people talked like that in the wild west,
then what?
Where did that go?
Where'd that go?
That all went into the ether,
like they had kids,
they raised their children.
The children are around this kind of language and somehow or another it escaped
and it went away and it stopped.
That's not how the world works.
Right.
The world doesn't work that way.
The world works in the way that like you slowly introduced fucked up words and
then they become like the word fuck.
If you said the word fuck on television in the 1950s,
you would get arrested.
Yeah.
Right.
How's that Pos staying on stage?
You get arrested,
Lenny Bruce,
George Carlin.
Uh,
how was it possible that that is a hundred years removed from people saying it
with abandoned constantly?
I don't believe it.
Yeah,
like I think a better example of what it was probably like his,
like gangs of New York and then it's probably more accurate.
Yeah.
Like that was probably what people were like.
Right.
Then there were probably brutal as fuck,
but I bet they didn't swear as much as we like to think they did the deadwood
thing,
it was like they were using it as a,
I mean maybe I need to go back and watch it before I talk shit.
But it felt like they were using it.
Almost like to modernize it.
Yeah.
Well you know they were having these people talk like scallywags would talk
today.
Right.
They also say cursing is cultural.
Like if you,
if you're in a,
uh,
you know,
they talk about how black people curse versus how Protestants curse coffee.
Yeah.
I'll have some more of that.
Did you have any,
will you have a name and a little bit,
just this article about,
it says that they purposely changed the words because to make it more
contemporary because people wouldn't have been buying if they're saying
tarnation and Gold Darren and shit like that.
Yeah,
yeah.
There you go.
What in Tarnation Glee.
But imagine if they did that with vikings.
You know like Yo,
we pillage and or what,
where are we doing dog the fuck I want to be
king of this bitch.
Yo saw let's let loose on this shit.
Let's let loose on these bitches.
Yeah.
I mean maybe that's,
that's real similar.
Yeah,
I'd see.
That's why.
Okay,
so I'm not wrong.
No,
they did it on purpose.
I bred the bringing it back.
They're making a movie or something or other.
I'd bring the series back cause it ended in the middle of season two when that
writer's strike happened,
I just kind of,
I heard there's a dope viking one that's on Netflix now.
I think it's a comedy.
Is it?
Oh yeah.
Norse nor scarves or something like that.
Now that's not the,
I don't think that's the one somebody else told me about one.
I think I'll put it on my phone cause I'm Norsemen Norseman does that it,
that might be it.
Is that,
is that a comedy?
Oh
it's weird.
My kids fucking curse and I never cursed around the house.
My wife crystal little,
but now suddenly it's okay and they're 15 and 18,
but it's suddenly okay that were at dinner and just fuck gets thrown around all
the time.
Like when did they,
when did I okay that
this it Norsemen it's just got a comedic vibe to it.
I don't know if it's like a full on.
Okay.
I'm just going to skip the whole thing.
This is
just based off of that.
I saw it.
I was like,
oh,
it looks like some Monte Python Shit.
Well why not?
I heard it's good though,
but I haven't,
I haven't at this might be it.
Yeah.
I was just too many new shells.
I can't keep,
I can't keep up.
I now,
yeah,
it's um,
it's like,
it's great.
This such high quality and things are so good,
but it's not great in that you can't keep up.
Have you started watching the marvelous Mrs Maizel?
Yeah,
I saw the first season and then maybe one or two of the second season,
but it just,
I really liked it.
I think she's fucking great.
Obviously the cast Tony Shalhoub but it just got so Jewish.
Don't say anything cause I'm,
I'm uh,
I'm just starting it.
Okay.
This is what I did.
I looked up,
I fucked up and started with season two.
How you did it started with episode one,
season two,
got to episode three.
I was like,
what's wrong with those?
That's hilarious.
No,
I didn't even know.
Somebody had to tell me.
Somebody had to tell me at the store,
I forget who told me.
But,
um,
I went back and watched the first episode of season one.
It was like,
Holy Shit,
this is even better.
But I thought it was good watching the first episode of season two,
not even knowing how she got there because I knew it was about stand up.
I knew she was a comic,
but then going back and watching it from season one,
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I think there's a lot,
there's a lot of stuff about how they ha and writing on a show that's similar
and that it's about a comedian starting out on crashing.
It's,
I think they really capture,
um,
the process of somebody brand new,
finding their voice on stage.
Yeah.
And the manager's grade,
the woman that plays her manager,
there's always somebody like that that's in your corner that's helping you
develop yourself.
Um,
and she's,
she's natural on stage.
I buy it.
I buy her as a standup on stage by her as being actually funny.
Yeah.
And it's interesting seeing Lenny Bruce,
the guy who plays with Lenny Bruce is very good.
Yeah.
Who is that guy?
Who's the,
who's her too?
Her name and spoil or you get to see her breasts call's fantastic by the way,
Lord.
Good Lord.
Thank you Jesus.
I had to do a search.
Not that I want to sound like,
but no,
I did a search on her news.
Just let it go.
I did a thing on her nude and
proud.
Put it up.
So you go for that.
Yeah.
Wow.
Rachel Brosnahan and I'm Mike [inaudible] and agile nasal.
Great.
And uh,
who is,
um,
who's playing Lenny Bruce?
Is that the guy?
Luke Kirby.
Outstanding.
He did a great job.
He,
he sounded like,
um,
you know,
he sounds,
without doing an obvious impression,
it sounds like it's got the tone right.
Yeah.
He's got the inflection,
right.
It's not overly stylized.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
and that you believe it.
he's,
he did a great job of like seeming like a guy doing standup in front of a room.
People not like an actor playing a stand up.
Well,
the woman that created the show,
apparently her dad was a standup and he knew Lenny Bruce,
which is why she put him in the series because he's the only historical figure
in the shell.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also the show.
They take some liberties with a history.
Like there was,
I don't think there was a comedy club back then,
you know,
this gas light,
they called it.
That's,
I don't think that was real.
I don't think there really was a comedy club back then.
I think back then people were just doing poetry nights and they were doing,
you know,
it'd be like a musician than a comedian.
Comedians would host things.
Right.
I don't think there was necessarily a comedy club.
Yeah,
I think that came later.
it's like catch a rising star came out of being a cabaret and you know,
people would sing there and then suddenly people started doing stand up there
and the two existed together for years before it became a comedy club.
We should,
we should actually know this.
Why do we not know what was the very first comedy club?
Well it was a catch.
There was the hungry eye in San Francisco.
Is that the first night and is the 60s though?
Was that when it's done?
Yeah,
that was the 60s because the ice house,
um,
is the oldest running comedy club in the world.
The ice was the oldest.
All the other old ones are gone except the ice house.
And the comedy and Magic Club is right on its heels.
Right.
That's,
that's probably second.
But what was the,
well that place is called The gas light and I think there was a gas light.
I think it was a comedy club though.
I don't think they,
the way they did it,
which was great.
And again,
I don't want to give,
give too much of it away,
but the way they did it where like people were getting bumped,
like she got bumped.
Yeah.
It's like,
I don't think that that was what guys did where they ran around doing 15 minutes
and go from one club to another the way in New York comics do it now.
I don't think that's real.
Yeah.
But that's a nit picky thing.
That's more,
you know,
it's more indicative I think of how people do it today.
You'd like,
do you think they were,
I mean,
who the fuck knows?
Maybe they had a drop in back then and maybe they did have nights,
like several nights where they had just comedy.
Yeah.
This is booked by a cliff nest off about the history of comedy.
You ever read that?
No,
he's great.
Um,
I don't know,
but it's cliff,
uh,
any s t e r o.
V and A.
I had him on my podcast a couple of times.
He's great.
But they,
the real first comedy shows in New York were,
um,
uh,
the Comedians,
drunks,
thieves,
scoundrels,
and the history of American comedy.
Um,
did you find anything about the oldest or the first standup comedy club?
Arguably in the United Kingdom in 1979,
it was the comedy store.
And before that there were just performing English motherfucker got ahold of
Wikipedia.
That's just started in United Kingdom and the United States history,
it goes back into the 19th century and Vaudeville places.
And so it just depends on when somebody first turned their venue.
But what I'm saying is who called who was,
who had the very serious comedy club?
Yeah,
the,
the Hungary I San Francisco.
Yeah.
So the hungry,
I was a 100% comedy club.
Yeah.
And then the bitter end,
which was music and comedy interesting in New York.
So those are the ones in,
what year is that?
Let's just says in the 50s into the 60s it doesn't have this particular year.
Wow.
Mort Saul,
I think Mort Saul still around Google that
I think he is.
I think he's still doing standup.
I think Dick [inaudible],
Dick Gregory's around.
See,
I think Dick Gregory died.
Oh,
he did?
True.
Find out that first cause I'm a dick,
I say died and he didn't.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Dick Gregory.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he died.
But I think Lenny Bruce might've started at the hungry eye as well.
I think he started in San Francisco.
I think you're right.
Yeah.
That was a,
the beatniks right?
Yeah.
Led into the,
is he still around?
Goddamn you Mort Saul still rocking 1991 years old motherfucker.
Wow.
Outlived them all.
Good for him.
Um,
yeah,
all these guys were the originators.
I mean,
without them.
These are,
this is the original roots of the tree of standup comedy.
100% right.
Yeah.
We do know James Googling shit
going back.
It's a crazy history.
You really stop and think about the year it starts in the 60s and that before
that it didn't exist like that.
Like it was kind of a thing that people did.
There was court jesters,
there was funny people,
there was comedy in various plays and musicals.
There was comp comedic elements.
But this cabaret,
yeah.
And there was MCS people would mc things.
But in terms of like someone going specifically to see someone say things in a
funny way,
just talking in front of a microphone.
That is really recent.
Yeah.
That's,
now imagine if we were born a hundred years ago.
What the fuck would we do?
Well,
we might,
we might have done,
um,
Vaudeville,
hang out with all those Vaudeville people.
I'd feel people where you go from town to town,
your beer,
your suitcase has no wheels on it.
The login,
that shit on a train.
Oh,
fun though.
Few Young.
Yeah.
For young it's probably fun because if you think you're a big deal when you go
to a town now go to fucking Columbus,
Ohio in 1919 and perform,
you would be like a god to them.
Yeah.
But you would also be like a carnie.
Traveling from town to town.
Probably fucking real loose with your morals.
Yeah.
Right.
Spreading God knows what around the Midwest,
all kinds of STDs and yeah.
Ious and babies constantly.
Nobody pulled out to use the wrapper.
1910s.
Right.
And they're also like,
they're living a savage life.
Like to expect them to find a nice gown,
Kansas and settle down.
That's right.
They're just,
they're working the tilt the world and they've got a prop it up with logs cause
the left side doesn't have a leg that thing spins.
So you got to keep an eye on it.
You don't want to launch anybody to the parking lot.
And if you do,
you just pack up and move to the next town.
They just get the fuck out of here is just no way to track on the Internet.
Yeah.
They say you know,
a lot of those early,
um,
it was very Jewish because Jews were having a hard time getting hired.
And so that was one of the few places they could work.
And that's why they say comedy was a very Jewish thing.
Oh,
interest leading into the Borscht belt and all that.
Stan and all of this,
but we just came out.
It's basically about this Lauren Harlow hardy were Vaudeville tour and comedians
in 1920s.
When did this come out?
Just came out.
It's in the theaters right now.
No Shit.
I have.
It has to be good.
But yeah,
about two weeks ago and Stan and all these stand for,
forget the Laurel and hardy,
right?
Yep.
It's a John C.
Reilly and Steve Coogan.
Wow.
Guys are both amazing.
Yeah.
Jonsi Raleigh's excellent.
I don't know who Steve Coogan is.
WHO's Steve Coogan?
I said British standup,
I think,
but uh,
that's cool.
I'm glad someone okay.
Oh,
I've seen that guy and stuff before.
I'm glad someone's doing that.
Charlie Chapman was supposedly a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
He would go up to the Hearst castle and fuck,
uh,
Eh,
hearse wife in the castle.
You ever go up to that castle?
Yeah.
When I was a little kid.
It's amazing.
And a,
yeah.
A chaplain would go up.
He was fucking everybody.
Everybody's wife.
Yeah.
Cheese.
He got off on wives.
Really?
Yeah.
That was a thing.
So dangerous.
Imagine the only happy if you're banging someone else's woman.
Wow.
That's crazy.
I guess there's no,
there's no commitment.
Maybe that,
and if she gets pregnant,
he'll claim it and he'll claim the baby that's them there at the Hearst castle.
Wow.
Whoa.
That scene with the cigarette.
Yeah.
That's so weird.
1930s banging her in the 60s
Hurst would have hundreds of guests every weekend.
They had rooms for hundreds of people and they would have hunts.
They would fucking hunt during the day or you know,
they play tennis and then everybody would meet for high balls at like five
o'clock in one room and giant fireplaces.
And they've set dinners with fucking servants.
And if you've got an invite to that,
he went for you go for like three weeks.
What?
Yeah,
you can look at that dining hall.
You know what that looks like?
It looks like the haunted dining hall in the Disney Rod.
The haunted mansion.
I don't know.
Pass the,
you ever seen that?
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Got inspired from something.
I guarantee that's what they got inspired by it.
It looks so much like that.
So look at that image right now and now Google the uh,
dining room at the haunted mansion,
Disneyland and all seen where you fly by and you're,
you're on the little train and you pass by and all the ghosts are dancing
around.
Shit.
It's cool.
It looks just like that.
Um,
and then it was a zoo.
All the grounds where a zoo at Hearst castle,
there was fucking giraffes running around zebras.
He's like El Chapo.
He couldn't get rid of his money.
He has so much fucking money.
That's a shit image of it.
They don't have a good image of it.
Oh,
all right.
Um,
how's that possible?
That really supposed to take pictures in there.
You,
that's a good point.
Yeah.
Wow.
So everybody,
but everybody does.
People are always taking pictures of shit.
You'd take pictures of your kids in there
anyway.
It looks real similar to that.
But yeah,
that guy had way too much money.
He brought over wild boars.
He's the reason why California has a wild pig problem.
Oh Shit.
Yes.
Wow.
Him that Fuck God damn.
Yeah.
Wild boars and they didn't,
they'd go hunt them.
Yeah,
he brought them here.
Wow.
That's why there's a whole like,
it's not down here.
So he's not in southern California.
They're all up there.
Yeah,
they're,
they're slowly making their way down here.
But the ones that are down here,
the closest they are is to hone ranch to hone ranches,
uh,
about an hour and a half from here.
And uh,
they have wild pig.
Is it that hard to just get a bunch of guys with AK 47 [inaudible] and hunt him
down.
Stop that hard.
But you can't do that in California,
California.
You can get depredation permits and they have gotten depredation permits and
they hunt them at night with night vision because sometimes the pigs will start
making their way into agriculture
or they start making their way into the,
like Dell lay down some fresh sod and put some grass down and these pigs will
destroy thousands of dollars in landscaping damage.
So yeah,
when they prove that that's happening,
then they get a special permit and then they can just start whacking.
Yeah.
And then they just take out like everything at night and they do it with,
you know,
sniper rifles and shit.
But then when I'm,
a normal person wants to like say if you wanted to kill a wild pig,
you can get as many licenses as you'd like.
You can get five licenses,
you can get six so you can go out and shoot six pigs in a day.
It's totally legal,
so long as you pay for each individual tag because the,
the understanding is that it,
at least in most places,
California's the only place that treats it like game and most places you don't
even have to have tags for them.
Most places they're encouraging you to shoot him and that'll probably be the
case in California eventually.
Like it isn't like Texas,
France for instance.
Right.
Texas has a real pig problem if they have a giant,
oh shit,
there's millions and millions and millions of pigs.
Oh,
I remember that from the Friday night late show at the Improv and Houston.
You said that with,
you really had me believing that you didn't believe it and you're setting up the
joke the whole time.
It's nice.
I think it's like that with alligators in Florida.
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
they were an endangered species.
They would ask us to please not feed the marshmallows because I lived in
Gainesville.
All right.
By this place called Lake Alice.
Yeah,
Lake Alice.
At alligators fucking 11 years old.
I was,
I was in an alligator's was crazy.
Yeah,
it was a goddamn dinosaur.
But there was a small population of them cause they had been whacked into
oblivion before and people are making suitcases out of them.
And then they made it illegal to hunt them and they made him a protected
species.
But then they fucked up.
They overprotected and those God damn super lizards are everywhere.
Fucking everywhere.
My mom belongs to a golf course down in Florida where she lives and there's this
alligator's apparently like this fucking 14 foot alligator.
And uh,
that people were playing golf and there was a deer and everybody's on the,
everybody's standing there going like,
it's a deer.
It's a deer.
Look at that.
Beautiful.
They're fucking alligator,
comes out,
grabs it,
pulls it into the water,
does that spin move?
Takes it to the bottom.
Fucking done.
So everyone's talking about it.
What do we do about it?
So about three weeks later,
my mom is out on the course and her ball is right next to the lake where the
alligator is and she forgets and she goes over and her ball is right on the edge
and she's standing there and she was standing on some fucking like dead,
some dead grass and it gave out and she fell in the fucking lake up to her neck.
And then she remembered and she fucking started scrambling up the mud and
grabbing if the reeds to get out of there.
And her and the people that who she was with had left,
she was by herself for
some reason and she fucking got out of there and got in the cart and,
and then she just started laughing.
Oh my God.
You believe that shit.
My little mother,
my little five foot two mother,
oh my God would have been a tasty meal happened so quick.
Better than a dear old lady.
Nice.
Soft.
All Lady.
Way more tender.
Yeah.
Corn Fed.
My mom's corn fed.
I never told you that.
Yeah.
I thought she was organic now.
No,
we let her free range.
Sometimes
there's a great story about a car chase.
The cops were chasing this too was stolen car and the guy jumps off a bridge
into the water and immediately gets eaten by alligators.
Wow.
He's like a little overpass over river,
which is hops out of the fucking car,
jumps into the river and smash.
He lands right in front of an alligator.
No Sheldon Jackson in front of the cops.
Wow.
What do you do
of your cop?
Do you shoot at the alligator?
Do you try to kill the alligator was killing the guy.
Good point.
I mean,
that's a reckless thing to be doing when there's a lot of thrashing around you
just going to empty your clip.
Pat,
pat,
you know,
I mean,
how much distance is there between the bridge and the water would right
do well,
you know the guy's going to die.
So I think it's,
I think it's a safe bet to take some shots
anyway.
I think it's a not safe bet to take some shots because if you're a cop would
have you hit the guy and they said,
oh,
you shot and trying to cover up by fucking alligators.
Eat them.
It's true.
You got to let the alligator eat them.
Now go save your job here about the guy who was the guy flying a plane from
Florida to Cuba or,
or Cuba to Florida,
and the plain fucking went down and he survived the crash and then got eaten by
sharks.
That's so fun.
Is that that 20 minute period where you're floating in the water,
but you're thankful and you're almost giddy?
I did it.
I fucking survived.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Bad Day.
Well,
you know that story about the World War Two boat that sank and the guys were
floating around at sea for several days and most of them got eaten by sharks.
Oof.
That's the store that they talk about in the beginning of jaws.
Yeah.
Remember where the captain,
the captains at the fucking scars,
and he starts talking about his,
uh,
his time on the boat.
Do you remember that scene?
Scheider no,
not Roy Scheider.
The guy was talking to Roy Scheider.
Okay.
Who's that guy?
What's that guy's name again?
Old Time Act to the guy was fucking amazing.
Spool up jaws to quick.
Richard Dreyfus.
No,
no,
no.
Richard Dreyfus was the scientist.
Roy Scheider was the sheriff.
And then there's,
uh,
an older gentleman.
Oh yeah.
Right.
He steals that fucking,
yeah,
he steals up movie.
Where is he?
Right here.
He
steals that fucking movie.
He steals how fucking movie you believe him.
Wait,
so what was the opening scene?
Not the opening scene,
but he describes what it was like.
No,
that's a different shark attack.
So typed in World War II.
Show the naval ship.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
I'm sorry.
I was thinking,
um,
when it says worst shark attack in history,
I was thinking it was that story about New Jersey where the bull sharks killed
people.
Scroll back up so I can see what it says here.
1945 US naval ship was sunk by a Japanese submarine.
The ship's sinking was just the beginning of the sailors nightmare.
Yeah.
That's the boat.
That's the story.
How many people died?
Hello?
Shit load.
Let's see,
that's 200 and oh don't most 300 people died of the 1,196 men aboard 900 made it
into the water alive.
Oh,
there are a deal.
So that's,
that's how many survived the crash.
So there's 900 of them that are alive now.
How many of them make it to the end
out of 900 scroll and Scroll and Scroll and Scroll up.
Data's pass.
Yeah,
this is,
they're just giving you the full line of the story that not giving you just the
actual facts.
317 317 remained.
So,
okay,
so almost 600 people got to eat
estimates of the number who die from shark attacks range from a few dozen to
almost 150
so the other people die from other things.
Starvation probably.
Oh,
heat stroke being in the water,
it could be a lot.
And so I bet when those guys died,
then the sharks ate them and it got even worse.
Fuck man.
Wow,
that's fucking crazy.
Just imagine 150 people eaten by sharks,
the amount of blood in the water fucking Christ
did.
You know?
But when you're around any kind of thing that can eat you and kill you,
it puts it all into perspective that you're not,
you're not around that enough.
And it's not,
it's not like you should be around it all the time,
but you should know it's a real thing.
And when you're around it,
you go like,
oh,
oh sharks just,
we'll just eat you.
Oh,
a bear will just eat you.
how bout in line?
We'll just eat you.
Oh,
like these people that got killed this year was a,
or 2018 at least,
was very rare.
And that two people were documented,
killed by mountain lions in the Pacific northwest.
One guy in Portland,
outside of Portland,
and one guy outside of Seattle.
It's pretty rare that mountain lions do that.
But Oh,
mountain lions would just eat you.
Oh,
that can happen too.
Like we think we're so safe
and I think it,
I think you're ready.
We'll keep you in the moment.
I think we should release like grizzly.
Yes,
in cities just because like you might be worried about,
oh,
am I the fucking stock market's down,
or I think my wife's cheating.
And you're right back in the,
yeah,
you're in the moment,
but then you're going to have to allow people to be armed to protect themselves.
Guys going to have open carry,
fucking ar slung around their shoulders looking out for bears everywhere.
Taking your kid to school,
you'd better bring the rifle.
She's only two blocks away,
bro.
Bringing the rifle.
I saw bear here a couple of days ago,
right?
Imagine you walk outside your house and you hear a branch snap and you turn and
you see a 900 pound wild dog like thing,
and that's not it.
That's not one shy.
That's gotta be a pretty good gun to take that thing down.
You're not going to take it out with like a nine millimeter.
Yeah.
It's just going to eat your bullets.
Right?
It's gonna kill you anyway.
Fuck yeah.
Okay.
You'd have to,
you'd have to have a perfect shot right in the perfect part of its brain to shut
it off quick to prevent you from getting mauled.
The amount of strength that they have to,
you'd be like a water balloon.
I feel like tearing open a bag.
Like a Ziploc bag full of Jello.
Yeah.
They just rip you apart.
He had gone back to that movie revenant.
That fucking bear attack was insane.
My bear tags nothing compared to what really happens.
Like if he really got bit by a bear be like that,
like he probably would be destroyed.
Like I think the guy that was the,
that we're really happened to them in real life.
It's kind of based really loosely on a story.
I think he got kind of like a little malt and that was enough.
Yeah.
A little malt leave you like that would that bear was throwing him around for
like,
yeah,
that bear would have killed you.
Yeah.
You'd have no bones left.
Right.
Snapped everything into a fine powder.
Just crush you and then eat you.
Right.
I'm fuck,
yeah.
Why not eat you?
Especially when she starts stinking.
They like to bury things,
let them rot for awhile.
They do.
My friend Adam and he shot a moose in Canada and a bear's claimed it and he went
back and there's a video of it.
It's so spooky.
Whoa.
Says buried.
It's a giant big ass moose.
By the time they got,
you know,
they shoot it and then it goes,
it runs away and then you have to track it.
You have to let it,
let it die.
It takes a little while.
So the smart thing to do is to sit out for a couple hours.
It'll be dead for sure.
But what you don't want to do is spook it while it's injured.
If,
if it's not a perfect hit,
if it runs away,
because then it's gonna just keep running.
You can run for a long time on adrenaline.
So the,
the,
the correct move is if you don't see an animal die,
you don't see,
you see it run into the woods.
You wait and you wait just as a precautionary mother.
Well,
the,
the animal died in seconds and a bear claimed it immediately.
It died probably right in front of them.
What state was this?
This was in Alaska.
So the bear is there.
The Moose dies right in front of them.
It's like,
oh look at that.
That's mine.
Yeah.
It starts eating it and he starts covering it up.
So eat some of it covers it up.
They come tracking and an hour later or so it's already covered in dirt.
Wow.
I'm like,
oh no,
that's crazy.
Oh yeah.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Fuck No.
I don't know.
Think about what would it take to take fucking frozen ground myself.
They might have shot it and taken some of the meat and we're going back to pack
it out.
Cause sometimes when you hunt you'll hunt with one person,
but when,
then you go back to pack out a big animal,
you bring like five or six guys to help you.
But this is the video of it.
They'll get this to give me some volume.
Oh Moose is very,
whoa,
okay.
Yeah I don't like this.
So everything is like,
you know,
five and a half feet high grass or you know,
you see how tall is that grass for four and a half feet at least.
Yeah.
So bears could be in that shit.
They could be hunkered down in that shit.
So I'm seeing the skull on the ground and the skull skinned out.
So what that means to me is that he had already started butchering the,
the Moose and probably went back to it.
So that's kind of correct that whether that was right about that or not,
but so this is what happened.
Um,
they can only take some of the meat because they were terrified the bear is
going to come back and I don't even think they had a gun on them and you know,
they're just scanning the area,
see how the,
the,
the moots the head is already off of the antlers,
you know?
And so this is the next video.
That's scary shit,
man.
So they didn't even see the bear.
They just know it was a bear.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Think about the strength to take frozen earth like that and dig it out.
What's the type of bear,
you know,
if you run into a black bear,
you're more likely to be thought of as food.
It's kind of interesting,
like you're more like,
like predation on humans is more common with black bears.
They just decide to try to eat you.
But uh,
with grizzlies,
grizzlies are rare.
It's rare that a grizzly decides to eat.
You decides to chase you down and eat you.
It's more common that you fuck up and run into a female or you try to steal his
food like that.
Like they had to get the fuck out of there because if he just decided to run at
them,
they got a real giant problem.
Most of the time of bear won't though.
They're cautious.
They'll stay,
they'll hang back cause they figured what are you going to do?
You're gonna eat that whole Moose.
You're going to leave me some.
I ate a bunch.
I'm going to wait a little while,
see what the fuck you're doing.
He's probably full anyway,
but they had to get out of there.
They only took her a little bit of the meat and they took off like this is too
dangerous.
Wow.
They used to be everywhere,
used to be everywhere in California.
That's why it's on our flag.
We killed them all,
not we.
You and I were in Boston.
Yeah.
We didn't kill anybody to kill anybody,
but they killed all the grizzly bears in California,
but it's still on under state flag.
The state flag hasn't a fucking grizzly bear,
but in California it doesn't have any grizzlies.
Right.
It's weird.
Yeah.
I was in Alaska once and they were,
they were like raccoons.
They were behind restaurants going through dumpsters,
grizzly walking around,
or brown bears or black bears.
I think they were.
I don't want,
other than that,
both,
they're both up there.
Black bears become more,
will they all become a problem if they start getting around garbage cause then
they're smart.
They know where the garbage is.
Just keep returning.
Right.
There's a place called Lovech,
the vet,
California.
It's off the five and it's named that way for the last guy to die in a bear
attack in California.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
They're like,
enough he fuck enough.
Apparently they wound up digging this guy up afterwards to find out the story is
true and he was just in pieces.
Shit.
Alright,
so coastal bear to bear,
bear attack,
shark attack or dying in a cryogenics tank dying the crow would be way less
painful.
You would just freeze.
That's the way to go.
I don't know if that's the way to go though,
because then you're not going to get eaten.
Like shouldn't you return to nature?
Yeah.
I mean you really should be eating and I would rather beat and by one of my con,
which is a ground animal,
those fucking cons in the water.
I get eaten by those heartless assholes and don't even take care of their
babies.
Yeah.
You know,
a bear at least takes care of their young,
I mean they're,
they're,
they're shit eds.
They eat their babies too and especially males.
Males killed babies left and right.
They actually actively go after them and kill them.
But sort of sharks,
sharks,
sharks have inter wound competition.
They eat each other inside the womb.
Oh no shit.
Wow.
You ever see like a,
an Mri of sharks in the womb?
Now it's a monster movie.
That's insane.
Is that Real,
those images?
That's a good question.
I've seen those elements that I feel like it might've been from a movie,
but I'm looking at now,
let's see.
I think it's real.
I think the reason why I thought it was fake and then I found out it was real.
It's one of those either I thought it was real and I found out it was fake or I
thought it was fake and I found out it's real.
But the image is,
if it's real,
it's fucking amazing.
It's these little monsters inside,
uh,
inside a womb and then you've got to think,
you know,
I guess no one had it.
Fuck it.
Cause they just lay the eggs out in the men just,
just on the eggs.
Really?
Yeah.
That's how it works.
They don't fuck a terrible life.
Wow.
Yeah.
The women lay the eggs on the floor.
I could salmon.
That's what happens.
That happens with trout.
They lay the eggs out in the men come by and shoot loads all over him.
And then the things pop up and no one takes care of anybody.
Wow.
All those kids that grow up without parents,
parents don't give a fuck about them.
The parents will eat them.
Yep.
Happens all the time with a little fish.
No bigger fishes.
Hunger this,
eat that.
They don't even know if there was parking.
I'm hitting it.
I'm hungry.
They just have,
they have a system of maintaining a population and when there's not enough food,
don't know.
Some of you guys got to go,
I don't remember this.
And Finding Nemo was,
it wasn't in there.
He fucking left it out.
They didn't even eat.
Yeah.
All those bare movies.
The movies about bears from Disney,
they don't eat.
Yeah.
How come they're not chasing down Moose and he didn't asshole first.
Hey
Taryn Bambi apart eaten her face while back.
Legs are kicking and the bears was holding him down.
Neat.
And like a grape eight.
That ass.
Yeah,
they go asshole first all the time.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's very inconvenient to show that in the lion king to show how the law,
how do these lines were there?
Where's their food?
And they never eat.
Everything's a battle.
There were going
to war with people trying to rein retain their kingdom.
Right.
Where's the snack?
Where's all the food?
Yeah.
How come?
How come I don't see that.
You're fucking with kids.
You're giving kids bad information.
That will be a great movie to do a feature late length animated movie where you
show how it really works.
Oh my God.
The killing.
Awful.
Yeah.
Be Awful.
Cats.
Cats are the population control of the world.
Those motherfuckers faster than everybody can only eat meat and all they do is
just run around and try to catch people slipping,
try to catch animals slipping,
tried to catch it,
and they're just,
they're just Darwinism.
Yeah.
They'll eat bugs in lion king.
Come on.
Yeah,
come on.
That's a bug that he just ate.
Yeah.
It was like,
uh,
he met Tomato Puma and he showed them how to get grubs or something like that.
And that's what ends up on me.
Fuck.
Kind of propaganda horse shit is this,
that God that's anti American.
What is the way his dad dies isn't a stampede of like Willdabeast,
which he probably was attack.
I just don't remember them showing that and that movie at all.
That's how they really see the problem is kids grow up and they see this stuff
and the soft headed amongst them.
Well then think that animals are really like that,
so they'll venture out into the forest to try to make friends.
You just have to be open spiritually.
Yeah.
Just go to the lion's den.
Open yourself up spiritually and let the forest,
no,
I talked to a lady once,
she was a yoga lady and she was talking about Colorado and she's like,
when I walk into the woods,
I just walk out there and say,
uh,
I'm walking out here with love.
Please do not harm me.
Like,
yeah,
that's not going to work.
They'd like to see you're having your period get back in the car.
Well,
not only that,
they don't,
it's not a morality thing.
It's not a good or bad thing.
It's like something's going to get eaten.
If you're out there and you're the slow thing,
you're going to get eaten.
No offense,
no one's mad at you.
It's just Darwinism that we calf.
Yeah.
This is not a,
this is not a discerning organism that's got moral value that it places on,
you know,
uh,
attacking thugs only or,
and not going after yoga instructors.
No slow shit that I can eat.
Yup.
There's,
they have no language.
They're just,
they're just an organism looking to survive complex set of reinforcements and
reward systems that are set up for it to be an incredibly efficient predator.
Fuck.
That's really,
see male lions the size of that fucking hall dude is the biggest jaws.
Do our full,
yeah.
So the shark thing,
I found articles saying what you were saying could not find a video.
And I do believe when we found that before it was fake and I'm trying to find
Google even like fake,
oh the sharping up.
The sharks in the body.
Just Google Mri image.
I found something to that kind of contradicts it though.
This is a dead shark that they performed a c section on and there was 98 live
pups and silent.
Yeah,
that's true.
But that doesn't mean that it happens every time.
I know.
What I had read was that it happens often.
This is the only thing I can find of a shark pregnancy.
That's 98 look at all those sharks has nuts,
and so he's just throwing them in the water.
He's pulling them out and saving them.
That is nuts,
man.
Look at all those little monsters just swarming around.
Do you know that?
Fuck.
That's crazy.
Do you know that millions,
literally millions of sharks are hunted and killed every year.
That's crazy.
Off the soup that she mostly,
yeah.
You know that's changed people's attitudes on shark fishing because people used
to catch shark and used to get it at restaurants all the time.
I don't remember.
You remember on the east coast he'd get Maaco Shark.
You thought you were fucking player,
right?
Pimp.
I'm getting some Sharay little lemon.
Some butter.
Yeah.
Right.
It was a common thing they'd serve in restaurants.
How many sharks are fence research indicates that about a hundred million sharks
are killed each year.
Wow.
Roughly 11,000 sharks and hour.
That is incredible.
This is by finning.
That's incredible.
It's likely that many sharks are caught without being reported.
Oh,
so the,
okay,
so this is just what the reporting my God,
so this is like the first time I can remember in history that people are
concerned with people fishing for sharks.
Because we talked about this was the the governor in New York.
Who Was it?
Who was the cat that got in trouble for legally catching a shark and cooking it
and eating it?
I want to say it was the governor and governor of New York,
but Cuomo,
I don't know,
something.
Maybe the government son,
whatever the fuck it is,
Jamie,
you'll find it.
Andrew Coma tweeted a picture of herself.
Yeah.
After he caught a shark or something like that.
Yeah,
so this was all normal when we were kids.
Yeah.
This was normal as fuck.
Like that might as well be a Marlin or a halibut.
It's just he got a shock like,
oh cool.
What's it taste like?
Oh,
it's good.
It's good.
You Cook it with lemon,
like swordfish,
very similar to something I remember eating shark.
Yeah.
It's a little tough.
I 100 Florida ft four pound thresher shark,
so that's um,
you know,
Maaco particularly delicious.
It really does taste a lot like swordfish,
but in our lifetime it's now become taboo because people have this rough idea of
what a shark is and the sharks are being targeted and sharks are being murdered
and there's a small amount of sharks left.
I don't know if that's accurate because I think this is just in one part of the
world,
they're killing off all these sharks.
It's like if you say that there's no more grizzly bears left.
Well if you're talking about California,
you're right,
but if you're talking about British Columbia,
you're wrong.
There is a fuck load of 'em up there and they're scary and they're big.
They're big and they're fast and they need to eat every day and they berries,
if they find berries,
they'll eat some berries or the asshole too.
I'd present.
Would you,
would you say
this is it,
this is happening,
is it,
let's do it right.
Is that,
I was in Alaska once and I was in,
uh,
I forget what town,
but there was a,
an island called Bair Island and I rented,
this guy had a,
had a 1948,
I think it was called us Stenson.
There's some kind of plane prop plane.
And I paid him a hundred bucks to take me over bear island in this fucking
shitty little plane.
And we went out there and it took him like 30 minutes to get the plane started
and that was like,
I should get the fuck outta here.
And so,
so we go up and a,
and the thing is getting tossed around by wind and uh,
and we go out and we go over bear island and he's showing me fucking bear all
over.
They would be like the highest concentration of bear and to anywhere in Alaska.
Jesus Christ,
those bears are giant tumor.
Yeah.
Those,
the coastal bears,
they're all eating seafood.
They're eating like fish and salmon and they just get enormous.
Yeah.
There so big.
There's so much bigger than bears that are inland like hundreds of pounds.
But what are the inland bears eat?
Wherever the fuck they get ahold of.
I'll eat salmon if they find salmon.
If there's the salmon river,
they'll eat fish.
They'll eat berries.
Oh,
he calves eat a lot of calves.
Did a lot of a calf's of a elk and Moose and deer.
Fauns the small things that can't get away.
They eat everything they can.
They're so big.
Yes.
It's just the two of you.
Imagine how much food you would have to eat if you weighed 800 pounds.
How much food would you have to eat?
Everything.
Well,
four times.
As much as you eat.
Now
look at that fucking creep.
Yeah,
look at that fucking long nailed creep.
That's a monster,
man.
Yeah.
Well we think it's Yogi.
Oh,
it's you.
You look,
he's so cute.
He will eat your kid in front of you.
Yeah,
and that's what they have to do.
I mean,
they're,
they're predators.
They're out there.
They're,
they're omnivores.
I mean,
they do occasionally eat whatever the fuck they want.
They'll eat roots and berries.
They'll eat everything else too,
but they'll definitely you and love it.
Yeah.
Have a good old time.
That's salmon's a perfect food for them.
It's all fat.
Yeah.
You just store it up.
Yup.
It's almost like it's designed for them too because the salmon die.
They literally die on the river.
Like you don't even have to catch him.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Every year when they have to die,
they go back up to where the corn,
right?
Yes.
They say that once the salmon make the trek from the ocean to the fresh water,
they're already on a path to die.
Their clock is already gone over.
It's already flipped over into no return land.
You couldn't take them out of there and bring them to like some salmon pawn.
They live forever.
It doesn't work that way.
There they,
they breed,
they make the track,
they breed and when they get to the spot where you know,
when there,
where the end of their life,
their,
their body starts changing color,
they getting mushy,
they live rotten and they just fucking wind up like pooling up on the ground.
And then the bears move in and they eat hundreds of rotten ones.
See,
this is,
this is while the salmon are in the run and these bears are,
they're fighting over territory.
Look at the size of these motherfuckers.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
they're fighting over who gets to salmon.
Yeah.
But these are salmon that are still pretty fresh and healthy.
They're,
they're swimming around,
they look good.
And so they catch them like that was a perfectly healthy salmon and he catches
it right in the middle of it or tried Huggies all slow mo and shit.
Here he goes.
They try and they catch some of them.
Oh,
come on bitch.
Hey,
get that.
Imagine just standing in freezing cold water waiting to catch something with
your mouth.
It's delicious.
Right.
But they figured it out and it works.
Yep.
Look at the cubs.
Like come on mom to fuck.
So mom's probably going to give him some of that.
Yeah,
see she breaks off pieces of it and so they just keep doing that back and forth.
And they'll do that all day.
But then once the salmon are done with their run,
then they just die.
And coincidentally when they're dying is probably right when the bears are
trying to fatten up and get ready for hibernation.
Yeah.
So it all like sort of happens together and they're all in the right place at
the right time.
See if you can find bears eating rotten salmon.
Cause like sometimes they'll pull up and these these rivers and these like
little ponds and shit and you just see all these bears is chew on these rotting
carcasses.
Yeah.
Those salmon are endangered now we eat so much more fish.
I remember when I was a kid,
I'd have fish once every three weeks.
Now you,
I mean maybe it's because we're in la,
but I have fished a few times a week.
Do you have some fucking Sushi?
One day wife will cook some salmon on another day.
Go get one of those pokie bowls.
We're constantly eating salmon.
It's a lot of food.
Think about all those little organisms that have to fuck,
well not really.
Shoot loads on eggs.
Yeah.
Make new organisms and then all the people with nets scooping them up.
Do you see us a tuna got sold in Japan for the highest amount ever.
$3 million for tuna?
Shit.
I had no idea.
And did you have any idea?
But a tuner could be 3 million.
Yeah,
I know that they wait on the dock and the in Japan and whoever is like certain
chefs have more cache and they're able to come in first and pick the,
the tuna.
But then they,
but then they auctioned them off and yeah,
they go for crazy money.
That's so crazy.
That's a giant fucking fish though.
Isn't it like 600 pounds or something?
How much it at least 278 kilograms.
What's that in English 2.2 close to six.
Yeah.
Look at that thing.
God Damn,
that's a hard,
that is to bring in.
Yeah.
I caught a yell tail and Hawaii.
That was like 11 pounds a battle.
What a battle.
Yeah.
613 pounds.
Wow.
Yeah,
we caught up quite a few of them.
You know what's interesting to catching ones they're calling Hamachi cause they
were actually from a Hamachi farm that was on the big island that broke during
the storm.
And when they had that storm,
there are a couple of years back.
Giant fucking hurricane.
They did a why?
Well it destroyed this uh,
this containment area that they had where they were farm raising Hamachi for
like Sushi and shit.
So now this type of yellow tails everywhere in the,
in the ocean.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
We caught a caught quite a few of them.
Did you eat them?
Yeah,
they're great.
So you caught it there,
you brought it back to the hotel and then they fried it down.
Pick it for you.
Yeah.
Oh it's amazing.
So good.
They made Sushi for us.
They made 'em.
They made a Sashimi,
they made some Che,
they baked it,
they cooked it a couple of different ways.
But you know,
they're so powerful.
A 10 pound one nine pound one or s is so powerful.
You can't believe how strong they are.
Like you're,
you're wrestling with them.
We can try and get him into the bullying.
So imagine that thing.
600 pounds and Holy Shit.
That's about the whole family fishing.
No,
just my youngest,
youngest daughter loves it.
She loves it.
Loves it.
She loves fishing.
Yeah.
We put a video up of,
um,
the dolphins that were with us.
I saw that.
It's crazy.
It was amazing.
They just never seen that many dolphins swim with a boat.
It was incredible.
They just all,
we just hit the right spot.
Yeah.
And then they all decided to swim with the boat.
They just get in the,
in front of the boat as the boat's pushing the water and they started a surf it,
that's amazing.
So crazy.
You worry about you're going to hit them.
You worry that they're going to the right people running the boat.
They don't worry about it.
All the dolphins know exactly what they're doing.
They're smart as shit.
Yeah.
It's weird to watch,
man.
It's weird to watch them all coordinate together and then they were done.
They were done like by,
they take off.
Wow.
Yeah.
My daughter's surfs and they come out.
They play around a little bit.
Sometimes they ride the waves when she surfing.
That's one of the dark sides of fishing,
right?
Commercial fishing is a,
what happens in Japan when they take those dolphins and they look at them as
competition,
they're going to kill their tuna.
So they,
you know,
they've been doing that forever.
The large scale slaughter of them,
it's scary shit.
They just shoot him.
They caught them.
They bring him.
You've ever seen the documentary,
the cove?
Oh No,
I heard about that.
All full.
It's all full there.
It's,
it's like they're slaughtering water people.
That's what it's like.
Yeah.
This is what a dolphin is,
is some strange,
super intelligent creature that we don't totally understand.
And they can talk,
they can talk to each other and we don't know what they're saying,
but they know what they're saying.
And we could train them.
You could ride them,
you can do it,
flips for fish,
all this kind of stuff.
That's all true.
But what's also true is they have a giant brain,
and if they have a huge brain,
Devin cerebral cortex is 40% larger than a person.
No Shit.
Yeah.
Wow.
They just,
it's designed for you,
the,
the movement of his body.
Cause it's a lot,
lot,
lot larger body,
but they think it's also got some sort of probably not totally understood are
measured cognitive ability.
They don't know like how smart they really are.
It's been,
you know,
when we're talking about Timothy Leary,
he used to pal around with John Lilly.
John Lilly's the guy who invented the isolation tank and he's also a,
he was a pioneer and interspecies communication.
You'd give dolphins acid and he would uh,
he was set the float tank up next to the dolphin tank and take acid and getting
there with them.
Yeah,
he was,
yeah.
He was trying to figure out a way to get dolphins to speak.
He would get them to like make a noise.
It sounds like how long,
you know,
but they could,
they don't have the vocal cords.
They can't make the sounds that we expect,
but there sounds we don't understand.
Right.
Which is weird cause they know what you're saying.
If you say,
okay,
we're going to jump now.
We've got a job,
we're going to give you a fish.
They know it.
They know what you're saying.
We have no idea what they're saying.
Yeah.
It's weird when you,
what?
What is the cutoff for killing an intelligent animal?
Right.
You know,
like you can't kill dogs.
Cats.
Dogs aren't nearly as smart as dolphins,
right?
Yeah.
But you can kill dogs in some spots.
It's cultural.
Yeah.
Because pigs are probably the smartest dogs.
Oh yeah.
We all exist.
Really smart.
I mean,
that's a,
that's a tricky one.
All those,
you know,
that is one of our criteria.
Like even a lot of vegetarians,
we'll still step on roaches.
Yeah.
You know,
our criteria is how smart is the thing.
How close is it to us?
The further it's away from us,
the easy we could just like,
nobody gives a fuck about oysters.
Yeah.
No.
Saben an oyster gets got.
I don't care.
I don't care at all.
I don't feel a thing.
Someone shucks annoy oyster and opens up and scooped it out and swallow.
And I'm like,
how's it?
Good.
Yeah.
I'm not like,
Aww,
poor little piggy.
But the poor little piggy that's real.
That thing.
Smart.
Oh,
let's say so.
Scared.
So terrified.
Yeah.
But it,
all those things are dumb.
What about lobsters getting thrown in the pot?
Can you do that?
I can't do that.
Oh yeah,
I could do.
It freaks me out that they're like moving around and alive and then you throw
them in and don't they scream they're bugs.
Yeah.
They scream.
They sing first and then this little screen,
they don't know.
It's not like the frog in Carnegie Hall.
They could make noise.
I'll leave the big noise.
Their lobsters.
Ah,
yeah.
But they tasted fuck.
I'll eat tons of them.
Ooh.
When I used to work in Boston at the,
uh,
the copy Marriott,
that was my day job for a while in college.
And then when I first started doing standup,
and we used to go down and it was the biggest banquet hall in Boston.
So we used to get all these conventions,
all these fucking hayseed farmers would come from the Midwest and they'd stay in
the hotel and they could order any kind of dinner.
They want it for their banquet.
But they always wanted the pilgrim,
the pilgrim banquet and used to have to fucking dress up as pilgrims who would
serve lobster.
It didn't even make any sense.
Thanks.
So,
so they would make,
and the thing about banquet cooking is you cook 10% more than the amount of
people you're feeding just in case,
which meant there was like,
you know,
30 30 college kids all waiting tables and uh,
and so after we fed them,
they would usually have like a presentation or whatever comedian or a speaker.
So we would leave the room for like an hour and a half and we would just fucking
go to town on like a hundred lobsters could eat like three lobsters if you
wanted.
And then our friends,
we're all working the bars.
They were all the bartenders so we'd be doing shots,
drinking beer and so is the upside was you live like a king.
The downside was you were dressed like a fucking asshole.
I remember clam bakes.
People would do them on the ball.
Yeah,
those were good.
Yeah.
I like a clam bake where you would burry it and put seaweed over the top and yet
wet seaweed and it would just steam everything.
I've never done it.
I've only eaten it at a restaurant.
When you order a clam bake and they give you some,
I've never done the beach thing.
I did it with Kevin Flynn and Nantucket.
God Damn,
it looks attractive.
Yeah,
that's very true.
Great.
Very earthy.
Right at the fucking corn in there.
Everything.
Potatoes to something about a bonfire on the beach,
right?
It's like extra special like here it is.
That's it right there.
How to make a steam pit.
Make a nice fuck and steam pit.
Look at that.
We've got a lobsters.
We got con con.
We got clams.
Yeah.
It would be lobsters and corn and clams.
Potatoes,
potatoes and it would all be buried in like a burlap sack under the ground.
Yup.
Muscles too.
God Damn it.
That locks kid.
Ah.
People say they don't like lobster.
I just do not understand that.
You don't what?
It's like lobster.
Eddie Bravo won't eat fish hate fish.
Big Fan.
You son of a bitch.
Some lobster and crab.
Nice Alaskan crab.
Look at that with the little,
with the green stuff.
What does that minced onions or something,
what does that look like?
Crow Crow.
I think what's,
no,
that's not,
that is,
that's like a spice,
right?
Cause it's on the corn to,
Oh yeah.
I think that's like a,
what is that?
Like a salary or something like that.
Parsley.
Chopped Parsley or some shit.
Just making it.
Oh,
and then the exit of the rail.
That's at the time.
That shit's nasty.
I like it.
You eat the rallied everything.
No Shit.
Chew the inner Cartlidge up and I suck the meat out of it.
I feel like if that thing is going to die,
I'm going to eat as much of it as I can.
I bite into the,
you know how you take the back and is that meat underneath with all the crazy
gills and all that shit.
I just chew into that stuff.
Really it chew it up,
chew it up.
Good junk.
All that shit and butter.
That's what I'm talking about,
Dan.
I did throw move on one of those waitresses.
I'm dressed as a pilgrim.
I'm drunk and on some girl from Boston College.
Did you know the lobsters were like poor people food in New York?
They would just go out to the East River and pull them out of the water.
Yeah.
Serve him as bar food for people.
Food.
Do you know an Ireland during the famine?
They were pulling fucking lobster out of the ocean would need it.
They considered it like rats.
Oh my God.
They sit.
They fucking need.
The British would just ship it off.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
I did not figure it out.
They're drunk.
One person just boiled it up,
made some butter.
Just shut the fuck up and try this.
Right.
People are like,
what
I've been avoiding.
Yes.
What does,
I've been thinking,
what the fuck have they been doing?
A lot.
It's the whole family is starving.
It's God damn delicious.
We've been eating potatoes.
We'd have been Indian.
This fucking lobster is fucking lucky charms.
Ah,
dude.
It's almost four o'clock.
No,
I've been rambling forever.
Yeah,
it's damn time warp in this building.
How long was,
how long?
We've been doing this for 17,
three hours and 17 minutes.
Damn.
Plus Vat for about a half hour before that.
Can I plug some dates?
Please do ladies and gentlemen live comedy comedy.
I'm going to be in Cleveland.
One of my favorite clubs.
Hilarides love that pledge.
January 17th through 19th.
That's a great spot.
Yeah.
I love that play in Boston.
I'll be in Boston.
Jen,
Laugh Boston.
January 31st last time I was in Cleveland.
You were in Cleveland and I did it with you.
That's right.
You stopped buying it.
The surprise guest spot.
That was fun.
Uh,
grand rapids,
Michigan,
uh,
in February and then a bunch of other dates coming in and best buddies.
I'm doing a benefit.
January 27th at the comedy store.
You around,
Bill Burr is going to be on the show.
Hang on a second.
I think you did it last year.
It's benefiting,
uh,
are definitely grouped.
It helps intellectually disabled people.
The 27th is a Sunday night.
Yeah,
I man Greg.
Got It.
Joe Rogan's in come see it.
And you,
man.
I've also got a new podcast with Alison Rosen called childish,
where we talk about raising kids together like her.
Isn't she great?
She's very cool.
Yeah,
I did her.
Um,
I've had her on and I did her when she was on Adam Carolla.
I did the show with her dumb together.
I like her a lot.
I think I did it a couple times with her and Adam.
Yeah.
We do each other's podcasts constantly and we just realized like,
she was my best chemistry.
So we just started a podcast.
Yeah.
She's,
uh,
she's kind,
she's super smart.
She's cool.
She's reasonable.
What she likes,
thinks about.
You can tell she's thinking about things,
right?
Yeah.
That's awesome man.
I'm glad you're doing that.
Yeah.
And what is it called again?
Childish.
She's got a baby and another one on the way and it's kind of me trying to teach
her how to parent and she's not buying it.
How many do we,
we just did one a week.
I think we've done like seven so far.
Nice.
And you still do your own,
right?
Yup.
Uh,
what's it called?
How many hours we've been talking.
We were burnt out.
Um,
Greg fits,
what does it fit?
Star Radio Com and
fits dog.com.
[inaudible] dot com [inaudible] dot com Greg Fitzsimmons on Instagram.
Um,
Greg Fitz show on Twitter.
Nice.
Yeah.
Come on man.
We're friends.
That's it.
You fucks.
Bye.
Love Ya.